ви також можете підняти руку, якщо
необхідно
будь ласка, зберігайте мікрофон формованим, якщо не
ти маєш поставити запитання
і це власне все
мережевий етикет, який ми можемо запропонувати вам, я сподіваюся, що ви
насолоджуйтесь зустріччю
гм, ми раді вітати
підписаний заступником генерального директора
дослідження та інновації європейського
комісію і здаю в
світ для вас
з задоволенням
багато багато
багато
Я думаю
Джулія також тут, тому сумую за дівчатами
і панове, доброго ранку всім
Дозвольте мені спочатку сердечно привітати вас
цей інформаційний день на Horizon Europe
і дуже вчасно тримати цю інформацію
день у день, як Horizon Europe Halls
вийшов у прямому ефірі у вівторок цього вівторка на
22 червня, а сьогоднішня мета – це
представити вам ці можливості та
сподіваюся, також стимулюватиме ваш інтерес
та мотивація подаватись на конкурси та
пропозиції ух і ух мені сказали
що їх понад 400
реєстрація для участі ух
тож ти, ось це справді добре
дозвольте мені нагадати вам про
співпраця досліджень та інновацій
ух між ух ЄС та Україною Україна
вже насолоджувався тим, що ми називаємо
Статус асоційованої країни з 2015 року
у нашій попередній програмі «Горизонт 2020».
а асоціація є найближчою формою
співробітництво, що означає, що дослідники
і інноватори в Україні змогли
щоб застосувати uh до uh виклики з
ті самі права, що й дослідники з ЄС
держав-членів
і фактично Україна цим скористалася
можливість добре знайомитися з укр
отримували бенефіціари
42,6 млн євро як прямі ЄС
внесок і це зрозуміло
збільшення порівняно з
29 мільйонів років, з яких ви отримали
це була б попередня дослідницька програма
сім, і це особливо вражає
оскільки ми знаємо, наскільки конкурентоспроможна ця програма
став тому я хотів би
повторіть успіх у чому
брати активну участь у Horizon Europe
водночас ми наполегливо працюємо
з українською владою до
завершити зараз практичний аспект
участі України
Асоціація повна Асоціація до Горизонт
Європа
тепер протягом сьогоднішнього дня ви будете
отримати детальну інформацію про
програма
я просто хочу підкреслити, як
участь у цій програмі
сприяє зміцненню наших зв'язків
з Україною вона бореться зі зміною клімату
це допомагає досягти сталого розвитку ООН
цілі розвитку, і він також спрямований на
підвищити конкурентоспроможність і зростання, і я
переконаний, що ці цілі також
поділилися українці через Горизонт
Європа, а Європейський Союз підтримує
що відродження інновацій є
важливий внесок у відновлення та
прискорення європейських континентів
зелена та цифрова трансформація та
це включає в себе природну торгівлю
інформація про дослідження також є ключовою
створювати та поширювати знання досконалості
компетенції в наших суспільствах, щоб зустрітися
наші спільні виклики
Нарешті Horizon Europe також рекламує ну
міцне міжнародне співробітництво та
тіснішої інтеграції України в
Європейські дослідження Інновації та
екосистеми освіти
uh українські дослідники uh новатори
заохочуються до об’єднання з ЄС
Партнери з підготовки пропозицій та до
справді зблизити Україну та ЄС
разом
Ваш статус кандидата в Асоціацію
країна дозволяє отримати доступ до всіх
інструменти вже програми на
цей етап, і дозвольте мені додати це
доповнення до сьогоднішньої конкретної інформації
день комісія також приймає
загальні інформаційні дні онлайн для заг
відкритий з наступного понеділка з 28 числа
червня до 9 липня і це
доповнить те, що ви тільки що почуєте
Тепер дозвольте мені закінчити, побажавши вам a
дуже корисний день отримання
інформації
з кінських уст так би мовити далі
the horizon Europe дуже дякую
Дякую, справді дякую за
цінні ідеї та вітаємо
слова від імені DG rni
гм насправді також спільні виклики
і можливості дуже важливі
для асоціації
і насправді тут є наша роль
є міжнародне співробітництво
об'єкт обслуговування європ
комісії, яка вітає також наших
офіційний співорганізатор Міністерство
Освіта і наука України дорог
Юлія
генерального директора дирекції ім
Наука та інновації
гм слово за вами, міністерство
Наука і освіта
також привітає
до учасників
велике спасибі за це
можливість дякую за Cigna це a
дуже приємно бачити вас усіх
сьогодні це також мені велике задоволення і
честь вітати вас на Horizon Europe
День інформації в Україні це а
знаменна справді значна подія для
нас так я вірю так що ми будемо
успішний сьогодні в обміні інформацією
та мотивація наших майбутніх учасників
також взяти участь у новій програмі
Я дам деякий огляд дій
які були зроблені на даний момент для нашого
Програма обіду в першу чергу я хочу
сказати спасибі нашим європейським колегам
за надання Технічно-експерт
підтримка цієї події також DG of for
дослідження та інновації європейського
комісії за їх постійну підтримку о
уся наша діяльність у приєднанні uh uh
Горизонт Європа, а також наша інтеграція
до епохи особливо я хотів би
висловлюю свою подяку Мартіну Феліксу
путівник по ТРЦ від Центру соц
Інновації також пан Вітале Бондюрант і
Пан Матіас спочатку з дилерського агентства
дякую за ваші зусилля
роблячи це спілкування і сьогодення
подія ну реальна я думаю це буде дуже
мотивація для всіх нас також у цьому
днів онлайн спілкування загалом
онлайн-спілкування, я думаю, це нам допомагає
щоб підтримувати зв’язок з Horizon Europe
рамкова програма ух об'єктів
співробітництво та посилює вплив
дослідницьких інновацій у розробці
підтримка та впровадження нових політик
приймаючи глобальні виклики для забезпечення
щоб Україна завершила все
необхідні кроки, які необхідні для
стати асоційованою країною в новому
рамкова програма, яку ми беремо і розмовляємо
деякі кроки, які необхідні, щоб бути
частину цієї програми ми під час кін
з 2020 і 2021 років у нас було три
етапи технології техн
дослідницькі переговори з європ
Комісія про майбутнє Об'єднання в
щоб зрозуміти деталі цих
майбутній прогрес також
хм, ми їх маємо на даний момент
офіційні делегації України в
переговори з Єврокомісією
на горизонті Європа і на євроатомі це
дуже важливо, що в цьому році ми маємо
ці процеси паралельно так від нашого
ми дійсно готові, і ми є
чекаємо переговорів ну ми ну
запланований перший етап офіц
переговори на 30 червня. Я сподіваюся, що ми це зробимо
вдасться почати це, тому що ми всі
дуже чекаю, і ну
попередній план полягає в тому, щоб підписати
договір десь жовтень 2021 року
тоді нам знадобляться деякі процедури всередині
Україна та Європейський Союз для того, щоб
зробіть це реальним, але розклад відповідає
одна рука дуже втомлена, а з іншого
дуже важливо, щоб ми з наших
а також наших європейських колег
роблять все для того, щоб бути
вчасно, тому що це дуже важливо, тому я
вважаю, що це також важливо
зрозуміти контекст, з яким
Україна розпочинає нову структуру
програми, так як учасник Асоційований
країни в попередніх рамках
програма Україна
показав дуже хороші результати і наш
На цьому наголошують і європейські колеги
так що це також дуже мотивує для нас
і наші учасники, тому що, можливо
під час я скажу пізніше, можливо, ні
все робилося для того, щоб
зміцнити потенціал Європейської Росії
Українських учасників, але дуже багато
кроки були зроблені, а також наші
учасники були дуже активними
активно вони знаходили своє
партнерів та створення співпраці та я
вважаю, що результати дуже вмотивовані
і тому ми випадково сьомі з 16
У нас також є асоційовані країни
надіслав, коли я побачу, що ми морозиво і
учасників
225 Грантові договори та чистий ви
внесок у межах цих грантів
угод є
45,3 млн євро хм 160 укр
організації взяли участь у цих
діяльність uh статистика дуже
цікаві в рамках розподілу
типи цих організацій ми знаємо
що одного цього 160 було більше ніж
50 відсотків приватних закладів
щось біля 20 вищих
освіти та дев'ять відсотків досліджень
установ чисті дослідницькі установи
звичайно для майбутньої рамки
програма, ми думаємо про це
розподіл, щоб сподобатися на одному
руку, щоб зробити все можливе, що
академічний сектор буде дуже активним і
ми сподіваємося успішно в програмі, але
також неурядові організації та приватний сектор
дуже важливо для нас також взяти до уваги
врахування акценту європ
Комісія з інновацій в рамках
це нова рамкова програма
вони також будуть дуже активними, так що
найактивніші українські учасники
в наступних темах це Моріс Кодовська
реакція безпечна, чиста та ефективна
енергетичні кліматичні дії та розумна екологія
і інтегрований транспорт
гм також
гм під час цього нашого періоду
хм програми хм Horizon 2020 хм ми
uh був активний uh um багато
діяльність з надання інформації
підвищення обізнаності вчених
та інші учасники про
можливості дзвінки і так далі у нас є
дуже активна мережа ncps це 38 в
момент у CPS, і ми сподіваємося, що це
мережа буде хотіти рости зміцнювати їх
потенціал, і ми намагаємося розробити
способи, як допомогти їм у їхній самій
нетривіальна і дуже важлива діяльність
хм ми хм хм я скажу про проблеми
а наше бачення рішень трохи пізніше
так і в нас було понад 70 укр
експертів і представників яких як хто
допомогти з реалізацією
оцінка та моніторинг горизонту
2020 рік
хм проекти ну ми це розуміємо
багато факторів є складними для нас і
тепер робимо наше домашнє завдання після їх
попередня програма Горизонт 2020 ми
зрозуміти, що існує ряд
питань, які кинули виклик нашим
Ефективність рівень успішності та
так далі так
зараз їх немає в списку The
Важливість тому, що вони важливі
для різних організацій і
різні дзвінки, але всі вони є
важливий перший — низький рівень
співпраці між наукою та
бізнес, звичайно, виклик для
багато країн, але ми бачимо, що багато
речі треба робити, нам подобається працювати
на законодавство і так далі але також
йдеться про комунікації про
мережі всередині країни, і я сподіваюся
що нам вдасться це вирішити
це наші наукові дані
інфраструктура, яка є великою
проблема української наукової сфери
тому що наші люди наші пошуки
дуже активні, дуже розумні, але все ж
рівень наукової інфраструктури як
погіршує наші результати, це як a
фінансування в науковій сфері ну так
це кидає виклик, наприклад, числу
молодих учених мотивація
люди люди тому і так далі
ізоляція ізоляція вашої наукової
дослідження реального сектору виробництва
посилання не так добре побудовані, як a
результат ми бачимо, що це як іноді
після прикладних досліджень немає можливості
продовжити далі і дослідник uh
окремий дослідник, якому вдалося за
приклад отримати фонд перед
Європейська комісія має розібратися особисто
як з правовою декомутацією, так і
фінансові питання замість обережного і
професійна характеристика в
наукова складова теж велика
проблема, але я так думаю
ми зробимо все можливе для вирішення
вони зовнішні, звичайно
для всіх асоційованих країн
високий рівень і не тільки пов'язаний з ним
високий рівень конкурентоспроможності
учасники добре це подобається
мотивація це про досконалість, але
все одно це для нас проблема
іноді це труднощі в боротьбі
зовнішніх партнерів для створення
ефективний конкурентний Консорціум і
відсутність роботи з процесом подання заявки
досвід ну так на даний момент це
головні проблеми, які ми бачимо, і якісь рішення
ми робимо різні речі, які можуть
допомогти зміцнити нашу наукову та
дослідницька інноваційна сфера, з одного боку
а з іншого не може зустрітися з цими
виклики це про створення та роботу
національного дослідницького фонду, який
зміцнити потенціал особистості
дослідники в даний момент, і ми сподіваємося
що в межах збільшення фінансування нім
зможе надати більше фінансування
Це також стосується дослідницької інфраструктури
грантової підтримки
протягом райдужної сесії гроші, які ми отримуємо
від Європейської комісії або всередині
Horizon 2020 і тепер вони будуть
надається на основі великого конкурсу
але також не тільки для проектів, але
також для дослідницької інфраструктури uh
йдеться про зміцнення нашого
можливості для кращого розповсюдження
відповідну інформацію про укр
організацій про дзвінки
і, як я вже сказав, справа не лише в
академічному секторі, а й про
підприємства та просто різні актори
в межах України, які здатні бути
конкурентоспроможний у своєму Horizon Europe
також це стосується мереж, тому що це
досить бідно в Україні, і ми сподіваємося
що деякі дії, які ми плануємо, допоможуть
виріши це
хм, ми хочемо зустріти кров для a
співробітництво з Європейським Союзом
і створюють свої ефективні мережі
не створювати, а підтримувати нашу мережу
NCP, щоб розвиватися, щоб
стати більш ефективним для більшого
освічені та добре підготовлені, а також ми
думаємо і сподіваюся, що нам це вдасться
створити центральний офіс, який буде
координує роботу НЦПД Укр
учасники допомагають із забезпеченням
інформацію забезпечують централізований ух
поради щодо того, як діяти в межах
Horizon Europe, і я думаю, що так і буде
дуже допомагати, і ми хочемо цього в майбутньому
мати такий інструмент для підтримки
ті, хто любить, показали ці проекти
та команд, які показали хороші результати
в межах Horizon Europe, але не зробив
перемога та причина так це відшкодування
інструмент, про який я вам розповідав раніше
про цю ідею також тому, що ваш
результат у цьому конкурсі буде
залежить від ваших результатів у межах
Горизонт 2020, але також і майбутнє
дуже важливо, тому що ми розуміємо
що є якесь радіо
ну працюй над тим, щоб стати відмінником, тому деякі
наших команд і учасників готові
виграти сьогодні, але деякі з них завдяки
конкурентоспроможності в рамках європейської
Союзні причини є великі
потенціал, але на даний момент не може бути е-е
переможець, щоб ми зрозуміли, що маємо
інвестувати в цих людей
команд, і ми матимемо ефект так
це як короткий огляд того, що ми
плануємо і що ми робимо
момент, коли я хочу сказати, що ми є
їду до нового як до переговорів
процес на даний момент і пізніше до
програмувати себе з розумінням цього
маємо в межах України на ст
на центральному рівні ми повинні зробити багато речей
щоб допомогти нашим учасникам бути
ефективні та конкурентоспроможні, але й ми
розуміти, що ми повинні інвестувати в наші
людей, а також у своїх знаннях і
їх здатність стати гравцями
у цій виставі ми маємо Within this
можливість горизонту Європа так я хочу
сказати спасибі нашому європейцю
колеги, я хочу запросити наших
Українським учасникам бути активними
слухати сьогодні та аналізувати це
інформацію, щоб бути готовим до планування
майбутню діяльність в рамках Horizon
Європа, якою, сподіваюся, ми станемо
асоційована країна трохи пізніше в
кінець року дуже дякую
дякую за важливі посилання
і конкретну інформацію про
мотивація переговорів широка
коло учасників, які наразі беруть участь у
попередники програми також на
система НКП майбутні структурні
змінює національні ядра, які подібні
додаткове керування мережею
можливості суб'єкта питання, пов'язані з
Програма Post підтримує все це
це дійсно важливо, дуже дякую
ми вдячні за це
ви відправили і запросили разом
з Вікторією це було як Вікторія
Гейгер був нашим співорганізатором у
процес, і це було приємно
готувати заходи разом з вами та
тому ми теж будемо продовжувати
нарешті, коли ми дивимося на порядок денний, ми
знайдіть також два імені тут і це
представляє міжнародне співробітництво
об'єкт обслуговування європ
Комісія
це ну вони технічні
організатори, у нас також є колега
німецький DLR, який працює над
технічна організація дякую Марія
за виконання цього завдання
у нас була чудова спільна робота для
підготовка цього інформаційного дня з
mezu, і з ним також чудово працювати
коментар у зібранні з майже 600
реєстрів зрозуміло, що завжди
половина з’являється так, що ось чому ми бачимо
зараз 240
колег, які приєдналися до цього заходу
це також диван навряд чи багатий номер і
ми говоримо про найкращий результат
для всього Східного партнерства
країн спростовує охоплення вашої
опорні структури та мережі в
країна, і це також показує вашу власну
потенціал ось про що можна сказати
цей пункт сьогодні ви побачите
презентації та отримувати інформацію
про це Verizon Europe повідомляє в
в двох словах про довгий список
можливості
однак ваші ведучі - дві особи
сьогодні ви бачите у своїй статі Віталія
ponderenko має величезний досвід
контактні тренінги та адвокація
заявників протягом багатьох років, і я б
хочу запросити Віталія представити
себе
тому, будь ласка, відплатіть, велике спасибі, Феліксе
дякую, але, можливо, ми спробуємо зробити
це трохи інтерактивно, я бачу Джулію
все ще з нами, можливо, є такі
питання до Юлії давайте свої
аудиторії надали можливість запитати у свого міністерства
і
можливо є якісь запитання до вас
можете використовувати чат для своїх запитань
або просто внизу у вас є
кнопка для реакцій і є a
кнопку підняття руки також там, щоб якщо
підніміть руку, ми можемо вимкнути звук
і гм
Ви можете поставити своє запитання І
дивіться, є один піднятий, і Марі може
увімкніть звук
Наталя
так, я вже маю
дякую, Наталя, продовжуй
поки немає питань
Гаразд
можливо є технічна проблема
ну
є ще один користувач
Анонімний користувач
чи можете ви ввімкнути звук нового користувача?
це вже вимкнено, так
Гаразд
тепер теж питання
тоді дозвольте мені почати з е-е
представляюся, і чи маєте ви
будь-які запитання, це чудово, що ти є
тут ви також, можливо, нам знадобиться
трохи часу, щоб підготувати наші запитання
виступаючи від імені учасників
тоді я просто можу заохотити вас це зробити
uh скористайтеся можливістю uh в порядку
поставити ваше служіння і ваші запитання
тому мене звуть віталій бандаринко працюю
у проекті Німецького аерокосмічного центру
управління агентство скорочена угода рпт
ну ми підрядники німця
Федеральне міністерство освіти і
Дослідження, і ми знаходимося в Бонні на
берег на березі прекрасного
річка Рейн
і я член німецького національного
контактний пункт для Marisco Rosca
кар'єрні дії та національний контакт
пункт для Європейської дослідницької ради
але сьогодні я дію
як підрядник цієї міжнар
обслуговуючий заклад і отримайте задоволення
трохи принести Horizon Europe
ближче до вас і
Гм, дивлячись на моє ім'я, ви можете це побачити
Я українського походження, тому так
і сказавши що здаю
назад до вас, verix
це так мило, що це велике задоволення
ти також командуєш українською бо якщо
є питання, а ти не ти
смію запитати їх англійською, не соромтеся я
зрозуміє лише трохи, але трохи
мм, мене звати Фелікс Кайсек, я працював
з 2009 року за рамковими програмами I
роботи у Відні в центрі соц
Інновація, яка є соціологічною наукою
організації, я був координатором
кількох проектів і партнерство в кількох
більше
для навчання у попередника
у програмі Horizon 2020 я також був a
тренер в Україні, це було великим задоволенням
бути там у 2019 році
все ніби закрили останнім
років тому ми бачили дуже
група ентузіастів на той час 20
людей, і це було справді чудово бачити
ви в дії, можливо, деякі з вас також
сьогодні тут
гм, сьогодні я зроблю свій внесок
відомості про вступ
введення в загальну програму і
вбудованість у стратегічні
рамках комісії і буду
також познайомити вас з
програма відбілювання пізніше, так що це
будуть мої частини, і я вже можу вас
знати порядок денний, який ви отримали
дивіться, ми вже закінчили з
вступ, але є трохи
додайте вміст мудрий це буде
тепер
хм, і насправді ми маємо
також перерва всередині ми також тоді a
закриття сесії, тож якщо у вас є
питання, які не підходять до сесії
зазначає їх, а потім ми повернемося
бути ми постараємося встигнути
гм так, але, можливо, ми трохи почали
раніше нам виповнилося 10 років
добре, так що вся ця підтримка
України та інших Східного партнерства
країни походить від проекту підтримки
фінансується Європейською Комісією
через важливість uh
включення країн – Україна
є той самий Центр підтримки, який
був у встановлений комісією і
це повинно сприяти подальшому включенню
України та дослідників і
новаторів, а також компаній у
рамкові програми та інше
пропоновані можливості
поставити мені не потрібно через це проходити
точно, але ви бачите тут те, що ми
у нас є кілька пропозицій для вас
інформаційний день, але ми також маємо також
табори для написання пропозицій, які ви бачите в Інтернеті
закон, тому надходить інша пропозиція
для вас це почнеться 12 липня і
триватиме до 16 липня, ми будемо онлайн
це можливість стати ближче
пропозиції та як ви можете бути більше
продуктивний залучений і все таке і
Є також індивідуальний експерт
консультації, які приходять на вимогу с
електронний лист, надісланий нам
тепер у вас є віртуальна половина дня
інформаційний день де ти зараз
давайте подивимось, скільки тут компаній
і якщо у вас є спеціальні запитання, це
може прийти, і ми маємо це для цього
написання пропозицій табори онлайн табори немає
такий привабливий, ніж справжній, але чудовий
і це піде до 20 вибраних
учасників тому є вид
форму заявки, яка вже є онлайн
і ми покажемо вам і поділимося з вами
посилання на це
добре, і ми організували це з
національний
контактні точки у нас є у вас є 38 дюймів
країна, яку ми чули, буде
інша координація, яка також підтримує
це так це як ідея і коли
ми приходимо до цієї пропозиції різноманітних таборів
ви бачите, що є поділ на три
часові проміжки, тож у вас є чотири години
одна дата і у вас один день перерви і
ще чотири години в середу, потім ви
знову зробити перерву, а потім мати
як відображення навколо так тут
гм, це означає, що між ними є
робота, і тут ви також бачите посилання ми
поділиться презентацією
відбір учасників не відбувається
за принципом «перший прийшов, перший обслужений».
він підбирається відповідно до того, скільки ви
мотивовані та що таке
суттєву інформацію, яку ви можете надати
ні, так, це буде практично
навчання буде інформація але
а також конкретні вказівки для пацієнта
і ми також розглянемо в конкретному
основні документи, з якими ви також зіткнетеся
до аеропорту
покладіть, а потім приготуємо
розділи пропозиції до розуміння
повністю те, що очікується і як це відбувається
зроблено
це свого роду змішаний підхід
тобто є як Практичний
навчання під час табору, але є
також є і ці консультації
потім, щоб ви, якщо ви дійсно йдете на
заявку з Партнерами або як
особи, тоді ви дійсно можете звернутися
тому ми більше працюємо над
Кооперативна частка в такому випадку
добре, тоді у вас є експерт
консультації після табору, якщо ви
Ви ентузіаст і маєте гарну ідею
у вас є мережа або просто є
ідея поки що немає мережі, це інше
час, коли ви можете звернутися до експерта
консультація
якщо ти справді так
um хочу висунути також
забезпечення виконання вашої лабораторії та
разом зі своєю командою ви як в
такі пропозиції або принаймні потрібні
певною мірою інституційна упаковка
тоді ви можете отримати це, і це приходить
за допомогою сеансів Skype або будь-якої іншої
взаємодія, яка підтримує вас
конкретні запитання, як їх вирішити
ось як працювати з цією проблемою в
пропозиція
і партнерство навколо
добре, а потім у вас було в останні дні
Європейські дослідження та інновації
днів, що дає трохи ширше уявлення
в поточний розвиток
так що ви можете піти в це е-е
у записах європ
Дні досліджень та інновацій
які основні зацікавлені сторони з
ЄС, а також ваші країни-члени та інші
як асоційовані країни
твердження щодо певних тем
це важливо, тому що вам потрібно мати a
фон, як перспектива, коли ви
підготувати заявку
[Музика]
добре, і ви також можете зв’язатися з нами
мати контактну адресу, де можна
як увійдіть і з нетерпінням чекайте всіх
проблеми, пов’язані з
консолідація тому, якщо спільне використання
зміст нашого інфотеку не повністю
працює, поки що це також можливість
для
короткий вступ до цієї теми, тому я
Є тут один слайд, який я хочу зробити
о так, це безсумнівно, отже, у вас є
власне огляд цікавого
програми, і я розповім вам, що ми
говорячи про те, що ви бачите ліву руку
Про Європейський оборонний фонд говорити не будемо
про вас права рука атом нафти
ми також не будемо говорити про сьогоднішній день, тому ви
не почує про це конкретно
питання підтримки
те, що ви почуєте сьогодні, ви побачите
в центрі є стовп один a
стовп другий і стовп третій
тому ми представимо вам ці стовпи
і якщо ви подивіться на самий
внизу, яке ви бачите зеленим, також є
інші більш горизонтальні питання, які будуть
бути адресованим
гм, тож ми повідомимо вас про
розширення участі щодо
до залучення країн, які є
не дуже людські країни вступають в a
конкретні заходи для підтримки цього
добре так і це все вбудовано в
порядок денний ви отримали, і насправді
ми маємо зараз це закрити
вступна сесія, і ми можемо йти, я
означає, що я повинен обговорити з Італією зараз, якщо
вам слід негайно перейти до цього
огляд
бо я хочу не втрачати часу
було б добре, я можу, я думаю, ми повинні
дайте трохи часу Джулії, тому що
є цікаве питання
які надійшли в чаті щодо
національне фінансування цих пропозицій
або ну
отримали високий рейтинг у Horizon
2020, наприклад, але не вдалося профінансувати
через обмежений бюджет, можливо, Джулія
міг би трохи пояснити
як я сказав у презентації
і я написав у вікні чату, яке у нас є
такий інструмент на даний момент ви так
Думаю, якщо все буде добре
ми почнемо виклик не пізніше
більше двох місяців
ну я думаю, що це дуже важливо
для учасників, які дійсно або
або
um мав хороший результат мав хороші результати
в рамках Horizon 2020 або ті, хто
є NCPS і нерозповсюдженими знаннями
уважно прочитайте цей документ, оскільки
там ви побачите процедуру
побачите їх типи грантів так
мова йде про інфраструктуру про проекти
або про інноваційні проекти тощо
а також є детальні ух
[Музика]
комутація, яка буде запитана з
учасники цього заклику так при цьому
момент, коли ви можете проаналізувати
цей документ і почати підготовку
для цього майбутнього виклику йдеться про
учасники горизонту 20, тому що ну
це в межах грошей
відшкодування, як я вже сказав, у нас було таке
um підтримка єврокомісара як
ми називаємо це е-е, я не готовий сказати вам
що буде пізніше, тому що на цьому
момент цей документ і ці гроші
про Horizon 2020. Я сподіваюся, що так і буде
бути як пілотна програма, програма для нас
для міністерства для уряду і
можливо, цей документ, сподіваюся, так і буде
розвиватися в іншій, про яку йтиметься
скоріше за підтримку Horizon Europe
успішні проекти, але на той момент
у нас є тільки інструмент про
горизонт 2010.
на європейському рівні таке є
ініціативний знак Excellence Julia I I
припустимо, ви знаєте про це, я можу просто
опублікуйте це в чаті, це те, що ми
знати від маршала безпеки
дії, наприклад, тому ті пропозиції
які отримали дуже високий рейтинг, але
не міг бути профінансований європейським
комісія пропонує їх профінансувати
на національному рівні це в основному
пояснення так Юлія
ми маємо
надіслав також зараз посилання на тільки що
сказати, що нам подобається Incorporated
в рамках цього інструменту, про який я говорю
також про підтримку та документацію
тому учасники повинні надати е-е
деякі документи про Печатку
досконалість та інші речі для того, щоб
показують, що вони займають високі позиції всередині
Horizon 2020, отже, цей інструмент
не про те, як підтримати всіх
які намагалися використовувати Horizon 2020, але
це буде досить конкурентоспроможним I I
надія, і це про вищий рейтинг
отримають ті, хто покаже свої
Високі результати в межах Horizon 2020
їхні деякі проекти дякую
і це звучить добре, тому що я маю на увазі вас
використовувати цей інструмент, запропонований
Європейська комісія через дзвінки до
Horizon 2020 і, звичайно,
процедуру оцінювання, і ви можете отримати вигоду
з цієї оцінки
який проводився експертами
Європейська комісія, на мене це чудово
особиста думка це дуже важливо
це адресація і це перевищення
ну політичне питання, як витік мізків як
чи можемо ми змінити відтік мізків на мізки?
тираж і я вважаю правильним
національне фінансування було б a
гарне вирішення цієї проблеми, дякую
Джулія, у нас є ще запитання
ще є три хвилини до цього
перерва на каву, тому скористайтеся нагодою запитати
ваше служіння
добре дякую велике Віталій і
Юлія мене Олександра хто запитав перший
питання і велике спасибі Юлія
для цієї відповіді, але в мене є ще одна
відповідь, яка важлива для всіх
у багатьох випадках ух
участь у Horizon 2020 немає
розглядав курс на нову ух
розвитку Лабораторії викл
vipment і так далі, так що в основному це так
вони вважають свою зарплату
витрати на поїздки і так далі, але
іноді нам потрібно спеціальне обладнання
і в цьому випадку ви враховуєте в цьому
нові інструменти для підтримки цих груп
які беруть участь у програмі Горизонт
щоб підтримати uh
бібліотеки цього обладнання до
лабораторії
дякую за це додаткове запитання
звичайно, буде чудово, якщо ви прийдете
у майбутньому ми матимемо такий інструмент
які ми можемо, як проходить базис мати
ті команди, які є ефективними
які виграють щось у Horizon Europe
отримати певну національну підтримку
гм, але на даний момент у нас такого немає
інструменти, які ми можемо запропонувати лише в межах
цей інструмент, про який ми говорили
відшкодування буде окремо
начебто частина присвячена
дослідницька інфраструктура, а також команди
які були успішними в рамках Horizon 2020
може, ух, можна буде подати заявку на
цієї частини фінансування та підтримки
інфраструктура, з іншого боку, ми
мати певну активність на даний момент
уряд був прийнятий uh прийнятий
концепція державної програми на ст
розвиток дослідницької інфраструктури I
сподіваюся, що в найближчому майбутньому
уряд також ухвалить uh
їх ця державна програма і там ми
мають розширений стратегічний погляд
як розвивати дослідницьку інфраструктуру
в україні як заробити стежити за цим як
щоб визначити пріоритети того, що ми маємо зробити
перший другий і так далі і також
буде весело, якщо фінансування
в рамках державної програми т. при
ми хочемо попрацювати ще над чимось
стратегічний
гм позицію деяких політик щодо цього
розвитку, але я сподіваюся, що в межах
різні подібні інструменти
інструменти відшкодування майбутні цілі
Національного наукового фонду NS тощо
на ми зможемо поставити лайк uh to to to
щоб доставити гроші цим командам
які є успішними
розвивати інфраструктуру так відповідь
на даний момент за замовчуванням і буде
бути деякими інструментами від штату
для підтримки дослідницької інфраструктури
але їх на даний момент не буде
присвячений самому Horizon Europe, але
у майбутньому також тому, що є в
В українському законодавстві такого немає
термін у Moment Like Horizon Europe
тому що домовленості немає
немає сертифіката про це
угода і так далі, і це чудово
проблема для нас, тому що навіть речі, які
сказано раніше про наприклад
Центр підтримки Horizon Europe and
тому нам проблематично це зробити
також через це законодавство
але я сподіваюся, Ед, ми будемо розвиватися підписати
ратифікація угоди і так перше
результатів буде легше
політичний і політичний рівень
така підтримка дякую
Велике спасибі, Джулія, і я можу додати, що е-е
Я маю на увазі Олександра, якщо ви говорите про нього
негайно потрібна інфраструктура
для реалізації вашого проекту
ти все ще можеш профінансувати це через це
проект, тому іноді ми беремо
норми амортизації для uh uh фінансування
певна інфраструктура, але звичайно
те, що сказав Уделл, це важливо
встановити своєрідне базове фінансування
на національному рівні також
правда, і у нас було ще одне запитання
щодо консультації спеціаліста Фелікс
не могли б ви розширити це питання
від sweetlana
мікрофон Фелікс
тому я побачив ще одне запитання
прийшов із Партнерства як
додаток, який є дуже хорошим
запитання
тому я не бачу проблеми з вами
сказати за участю в
Табори з написання пропозицій
і для є одне питання, яке
питання, чи це ви маєте на увазі?
від Світлани Ілнесської
10 38 питання щодо двостороннього
експертиза
призначений для всіх тем у Horizon
Європа лише деякі окремі, так
ну що стосується консультацій експертів
хм, якщо ви вже знаєте тему
цікавить конкретна сфера і ви
є певне запитання, на яке ми можемо відповісти
всі питання так немає обмежень
ми скажемо вам, якщо ви не знаємо
достатньо, щоб підтримати вас, тому що це також
може трапитися, тоді вам доведеться, можливо, отримати
ближче до вашого національного контактного пункту
роз'яснити питання або ми можемо знайти також як
більше інформації uh спільно з вами, але
ми не бачили питання, яке ми це
ми не змогли відповісти хоча б узагальнено
і як отримати більше інформації
тому зазвичай запитання схожі на a
структура
можна відповісти на основі інформації
у нас також є з минулого, тому я думаю
ви можете вільно звертатися до будь-чого
можливо, можливо, ми бачимо окремих
стипендій це було б найбільше
складно, але Віталій також дуже
поінформований про ці проблеми, так, але
для всіх дзвінків, куди вам потрібно
Партнери ми добре підготовлені Я б
скажи, ну, ну, я думаю, що це так
добре так
але ви повинні щось там визначити
також було питання, чи можу я подати заявку як
організація лише певна
демонструвати
це дуже гарне запитання
але я маю на увазі, що це залежить від самого цього
виражений
можливість, яку ви знаходите тут, коли ви
подивіться на цю картинку посередині себе
см кластери
все це, наприклад, і це a
дуже велика дуже велика частина це все
оперативні зусилля Консорціуму
зазвичай у вас є лише дані консорціумів
отримання тут, але є певні
речі, які не пов'язані з консульством
команди, щоб ви мали конкретні
інструменти, які можуть бути чудовими для
наприклад, але ви почуєте про це a
трохи пізніше, немає потреби
уточнити, що зараз, але зазвичай
якщо ви йдете з ними в тематичному
Напрямок, з якого вам також потрібні партнери
за кордоном не кажуть, що в країні
але з-за кордону вам потрібне партнерство
у звичайному випадку всіх цих викликів
але не для окремих осіб чи для деяких
який може бути відмінним, а також
розширення участі або деякі проблеми
Фелікс, дозволь мені заскочити, є один
Цікаве запитання від Олександра
Беббідж ну написано українською
Олександр, ви б хотіли розширити a
трохи на це питання, тому що я
не знаю, хто ми, хто ти
питаючи, що таке відповідь
ви очікували було свого роду зауваження I
розумію вашу точку зору, але, можливо, ви
хотів би пояснити, як це виглядає
щоб продовжити тут
ти можеш попросити вимкнути звук так
ти мене чуєш, ми тебе чуємо, о
дякую, ми говоримо про це
якусь позицію, коли ми в нашому гранті
угоду та деякі зобов’язання з боку нашої
консорціуми, то ми
може можливість поділитися деякими
інформація чи ні
є підписка про нерозголошення
в Консорціумі, отже, ви
потрібно
в основному, якщо тримати язик за зубами, так
батькові
Фінансовий від
Європейська комісія обговорювала
на україні на рівні ух
ну які наші
Державна влада уряду в
відомий рівень, який може підтримувати наше міністерство
цих колективів і університетів на а
національний рівень
тож це було запитання до
міністерство як я розумію так так так
це не для європейського рівня, а тільки на
національний рівень
область, будь ласка, можете відповісти на це запитання
пункти моменту, щоб коротко процитував
рядки з їх офіційного документа, який
нам знадобиться яка інформація
у вашому проекті в Horizon
2020, тому вони ніби написані як ви
повинні надати і в тому випадку, якщо ви
не можемо це забезпечити, ми нічого не можемо зробити
тому що це ніби ця інформація
потрібен для того, щоб показати свій
результат
тому я думаю, що так і будемо я думаю, що це
цікавий випадок
гм, я думаю, Вікторія Хайдар буде
спілкуватися з вами безпосередньо з цього приводу
проблема, якщо це як складно для таких
участь, але на даний момент я можу
скажи, щоб ми, як ти знаєш, для усиновлення
цього документа або цього акта
уряд у нас є рік на рік для нового
ітерації та за кілька років до цього
Звичайно, ми зацікавлені не починати це
тому що ми на самому початку
нова рамкова програма і ми
розуміємо, що ми втрачаємо час на
посилення дієздатності тих, хто є
може бути дуже ефективним у вашому
рамкова програма, тому цей інструмент
буде працювати так, як зараз написано, але для
майбутнє це дуже важливо для нас
аналізувати такі випадки і, можливо, до
розробити певний спосіб, як діяти далі
з такими ситуаціями це все від мене
на даний момент велике спасибі Julia and
виникає одне цікаве питання
від від Катарини крушевської
ну, щодо приєднання до консорціумів і
вже є хороша відповідь від
Вікторія
uh посилаючись на портал учасників
або планування та тендерні можливості
портал, я також можу додати, що ви можете
використовувати базу даних chordies
хм Катаріна, наприклад, давайте я опублікую
це посилання це a
довго над чатом
але це як ви можете визначити
пропозиції ух від певного виклику для
це приклад бази даних Cordis
тепер посилання на Марію Кюрі
індивідуальні стипендії до 2020 року
це в основному всі проекти
гм
які фінансувалися з Німеччини та
це шлях, яким ви можете продовжувати
щоб ідентифікувати будь-який проект будь-який
конкретний дзвінок, а потім дізнатися, хто
були успішними в попередньому виклику для
приклад у подібному виклику, а потім ви
можна спробувати зв’язатися з цими установами
це теж буде другий варіант
так наскільки я бачу
Існує
без питань Юлія так
взяти слово
Я також бачу одне запитання від
які плани укр
уряд працювати на периферії
законодавство про податок Horizon Europe
режими для суб'єктів, як державні
організація може виплачувати заробітну плату в межах
Зростаюча Європа явно наближається до ярмарку
правила, як
держав-членів, тому це складна частина
для нас тому що на даний момент черепно-мозкова
законодавство не є
настільки гнучким, наскільки це має бути, щоб
зробіть своє життя українським
учасникам легше, як я вже згадував у
презентація це ну це стає
привести проблему їх переможця
Український учасник, який став переможцем
оскільки
хм, тому що нам це подобається
гнучкість Я так думаю
гм, щось, що ми намагаємось уточнити
різні варіанти але укр
законодавство про уряд
організації дуже схожі на жорсткі і це
поширюється на всі організації
в результаті, коли ми намагаємося змінитися
щось тільки для університетів і
наукових установ з метою допом
їх у питаннях, наприклад, що стосуються
міжнародне співробітництво та
Зокрема, ми бачимо, що це так
як нетривіальний, він потребує широкого
діалог між різними акторами
в т. ч. Мінфін розн
Комітети роботи Наради тощо
на це в даний момент це дуже
політичне питання, тому що це як
основи законодавства про
урядова організація є частиною
філософія бюджетної сфери
Україна, я сподіваюся, що ми зможемо
змінити хоч щось всередині так при
ми знаходимося на завершальному етапі
ратифікації двосторонніх
угоду з Європейським Союзом про
науково-технічна корпорація
це передбачає деякі деякі деякі деякі деякі
спеціальні режими на
для тих, хто має проекти
Європейський Союз, і я сподіваюся, що ми це зробимо
розробити щось, щоб допомогти
Українські учасники, але на даний момент
Я, на жаль, можу сказати, що деякі великі
зміни, які потрібні, які є
дійсно необхідні для того, щоб зробити
процесів легше, це частина більшого
ширше, наприклад, залучення зацікавлених сторін
ніж це можна зробити з міністерства
Спасибі вам сама освіта і наука
Велике спасибі Юлія за щирі слова
і Ігоря ви б хотіли прокоментувати
це ви висловили своє бажання
повідомте про це онлайн
так
дякую дякую в основному ви майже
відповів на моє запитання, тому я просто хочу
просто сформулюйте більше своїх проблем
тому що я виступаю в Україні як
ну ми беремо участь, ми читаємо пропозиції
і ми залучили стільки зацікавлених сторін, скільки
найкраще з України в якості користування
випадків і користувачів і дійсно є Партнерами
в пропозиції і справа так і є
це лише половина історії, коли ми
виграти проект, у нас є все це
кошмари з поясненням, що ми можемо зробити
що ми можемо зробити
і так в основному
як я вже сказав, я маю на увазі, наприклад
уряд запроваджує dscd для
наприклад, і немає способу let's
сказати НДІ в Нац
Академія наук бути в тому податку
режим правий, а потім ух так Національний
Академія наук неконкурентоспроможна
тут те саме з юридичними особами в
є багато держав-членів
конкретні речі лише тому, що Horizon
Європа, наприклад, Verizon 2020
дуже специфічне законодавство, я маю на увазі нас
була така співпраця, ми мали певний податок
режими імпорту та митні для тех
проекти та інші проекти о
співпраці, але ми не мали
все, що стосується справжнього проведення цього
досліджуйте правильно, тому, можливо, якщо ми це матимемо
сегрегація, я маю на увазі, що ми маємо ці е-е
угоди з ЄС, і ми кажемо, що все добре
імпортні речі будуть звільнені
правильно, і ми можемо сказати те саме для I
не знаю підходу до зарплати
найму людей певні податкові режими або
що-небудь або з іншого боку, ми повинні сказати
це нормально, усі ці ініціативи
такого уряду, як DSE, я не знаю
я маю на увазі цей режим, якщо такий конкурентний
чи ні, але все одно ми повинні це сказати
цей специфічний податковий режим є
також доступні для дослідницьких організацій
це лише мої думки щодо
це
тому я впевнений, що нам потрібно уточнити
трохи Pacifica, тому що це як справді
як кошмар, тому люди ті, хто є
переможців, які активні і які є
здатний любити вигравати в межах
конкурентоспроможний Horizon Europe Horizon 2020
наприклад проекти, які вони страждають пізніше
в рамках українського законодавства намагається
робити те, на що вони схожі
держави, і вони будуть робити в межах нашої
реальність і це дуже дивна ситуація
напевно, але зараз так
гм це так я б сказав, як a
філософськи це справа для того, щоб
як додати до коментаря до мого попереднього
те, що я сказав, я не можу нічого змінити
це в тій відповіді, коли наука і
Інновації стануть вищими
Український політичний порядок денний тоді такий
питання будуть уточнюватися детальніше
ефективно можливо швидше можливо на
вищий політичний рівень і так далі тому що
звичайно, коли ми читаємо for
Приклад договору про асоціацію
Україна та інше з цим див
що деякі частини дуже продумані
глибоко і докладно і про в
Наука Інновації це лише кілька
абзаци з деякими дуже
загальний текст, напевно, це так, як є
про присвяту країни на
найвищий політичний рівень у цих
речі в розумінні того, що це
важливо розуміти, що у вас є
зробити якомога більше для того, щоб
зробити в межах України конкурентоспроможну ух
ситуація, щоб люди залишалися тут
і використовуйте можливості, наприклад або
рамкові програми Європейського Союзу I
думати в принципі в ген в майбутньому ми
можна очікувати цього в той момент, коли ми робимо
все можливе на нашому рівні ми
ініціювати такі дискусії, які ми ініціюємо
таких документів ми створюємо робочі місця цього
документ і поділитися ним з іншими
Міністерства і намагаються
підтримувати цей діалог, щоб вони могли
зрозуміти нашу точку зору
аргументація та чому це важливо для
Україна, тож ми в процесі, я сподіваюся
що разом з вами з
зацікавлені сторони основні зацікавлені сторони
процесу ми зможемо це змінити
люблю
це місце в політичному агенті
за всі ці запитання дякую
Велике спасибі, Джуліан Фелікс, ти дав мені
підпис, коли ви хочете почати з
загальна презентація, але я думаю, що ми
слід спробувати взяти кілька
запитання, якщо ви не проти
так, я думаю, що краще запитати
якщо надходять додаткові запитання
у тому ж напрямку, що насправді
сенс запитати
Дякую
гм, я маю на увазі причину
одне гарне запитання німецькою
Visa blue takeing uh я відповідаю
Англійська, тому що
тепер ви бачите структуру горизонту
Європа на вашому екрані і це
в основному відповідь Horizon Europe - це a
рамкова програма досліджень і
Інновації, отже, дослідження – це ваші
Дослідження ключових слів та інновації
у стовпі 2 ви бачите цю шість
кластери і, можливо, ви знайдете для
приклад виклику всередині кластера
um культура творчість та інклюзивність
Суспільство або якщо мова йде про цифровізацію
вашої бібліотеки, можливо, це в межах
кластер цифрової промисловості та космосу та
так далі і так далі в основному вам потрібно a
проект, вам потрібна ідея, ким ви є
збирається зробити з точки зору дослідження та
Ідеться не лише про інновації
це збереження ваших ресурсів
про інноваційну дослідницьку ідею, сподіваюся, моя
відповідь зрозуміла, а у Фелікса одне запитання
два, можливо, ви можете трохи пояснити
трохи знову
умови приєднання до пропозиції
написання табору, здається, не зрозуміло
так
якщо ви підете, пропозиція буде написана
на сторінку є кілька каналів ви
потрібно заповнити, і коли ви туди підете
ви знайдете поля, які постачаються з
ваша мотивація, визначте теми
Ви маєте певні підготовчі кроки
вже взято і тому подібне
інформація береться тоді ну якщо є
багато додатків, які нам доведеться використовувати
вибрати
і все, що ми знайдемо, є інформація
буде використано для вибору uh там буде
як своєрідна оцінка в
іншого способу немає
як потрапити до 20 найкращих
тому я маю на увазі, якщо у нас є 21 найкраща людина, запитайте
21 найкращий або 25 найкращих для участі, але
так, я думаю, це ваші межі
справді може служити групі людей
достатньо, лише якщо вони є
не надто великий
а також будуть дискусії та
Підготовчі роботи
конкурувати за людей і з нашого боку так
це лише ті обмеження
те, як це робиться, я теж бачив
інше питання в межах діаграми, яка
прийшли з відношенням до успішності
досить цікаве питання досить
цікаво в останньому Horizon 2020
назва якого є попередником the
організації, куди я також передав
в 30 пропозиціях на 24 не знаю
точно є тільки один ми
виграв, і це було в пріоритеті, який був
переписаний 200 до 1 із 197 був
фінансуються були щось подібне так
але це була соціальна наука
але я маю на увазі, що це залежить від того, наскільки конкретно
ви працюєте над темою, як ви чудово
наскільки доповнюють усі ваші роботи
і ваші високоповажності всередині
партнерство
і що ви пропонуєте і що таке
основа, на якій ви базуєте свої пропозиції I
насправді означають анти-амбіції розвиватися
далі і, звичайно, це оцінюється
є певний спосіб оцінки
це справедливо в моїй сфері, але
Звичайно, я маю на увазі, якщо у вас є
197 заявок на одну тему, яка є
дійсно дивно
можливо, також бракує, тому що я
були кращі пропозиції, які не виграли
але тут ми отримали 15 балів, тому будемо
не інформувати вас про цю оцінку
процедура в деталях сьогодні, але те, що ми
зробимо, ми дамо вам передісторію
подивіться також, які стратегічні цілі
комісії та в межах в
Європейський дослідницький простір і, можливо, це так
час почати цю презентацію
буквально so so we should and and Maria
подобається рухатися вперед з тим, щоб віддавати
ти просто дозволь мені дати один
коротка відповідь на останнє запитання
Олена Олена, це ваша робота
визначити в стовпі 2 справа
кластер uh to застосувати uh для певного
дзвоніть, але я трохи розповім про це
трохи пізніше, коли я також представлю стовп
дякую, Феліксе, я маю на увазі як генерал
підхід, який ви зараз почуєте, як
фон, який приходить, як приходить
Horizon Europe і чому це важливо
для Європи ви почуєте це від мене
бік
але у вас також є інституція
точки зору ви походите з an
організації, з якою ви працюєте
організація, в якій ви працюєте дослідником
можливо, підприємець або ви
інноватор або керівник групи, яка це робить
такі речі, як я описую, ви також маєте
інституційну перспективу, яку ви хочете
отримати нові знання не лише тому, що ви
можна отримати трохи фінансування, так, але
це також приблизно як прогрес власного
працювати над спільним мисленням, я маю на увазі
в той же час думаючи про
Європейський прогрес – це добре, тому
вам потрібна інформація, яку я вам даю, але
нарешті, його також потрібно вбудувати
ваша логіка вашої організації та її
певним чином хотів би матерію всередині
гм добре
поки що я почну з цього
всередині
які представлені тут на багатьох слайдах
будь ласка, сприймайте це як огляд, але
для самої підготовки ви повинні піти
знову в нього та подивіться, чи все це підходить
який схожий який фон так
є цей гарний е-е
um гасло інвестування для формування нашого майбутнього
ви чули це багато разів
але це схоже на ідею мати
програма зверху вниз тематична зверху вниз с
кілька елементів знизу вгору
і я хотів би показати вам логіку
за ним, отже, це комісар
відповідальний за дослідження та інновації
культурно-освітнього використання так профес
поле, яке вона покриває дуже добре
комісар до речі і хороший
огляд усіх питань, тому ми
будуючи Horizon Europe на основі
цей Horizon 2020, який був останнім
програма фінансування, з якою вона знову йде
це проривна інновація
знову з інноваціями, і вони з’являються знову
з
проблеми, викликані впливом, з якими він також пов’язаний
місії з певними полями, які ми маємо
стати активним як Товариство для формування
відповідні партнерства, які можуть зустрітися
нинішні виклики просто подобаються
звернемося до цього, і фактично ми дивимося з
цей Horizon Europe на стійкий
цілі розвитку, які були розроблені
за останнє десятиліття фактично і це
виглядає все в цих питаннях, щоб подивитися на
проблеми зміни клімату, на які варто звернути увагу
sdgs to boost to boost their
конкурентоспроможність і роль ЄС і
Асоційовані країни та утворити також
Європейський дослідницький простір
дивитися також на кращий вплив
дослідження та охоплення суспільства та
Що стосується Outreach, ви можете мати на увазі
прямий охоплення результатів, але це
також потрібно шукати роботу
створення
використовувати інструмент EU Talent, а також
резерв талантів асоційованих країн, який
приходить із економічним зростанням, а також
європейський дослідницький простір, який схожий на
концепція, яка постійно схожа
обслуговування так європейських досліджень
область трохи схожа на контрастну, яка була
США роблять дещо протилежні цьому
Так робить Китай і Японія
це схоже на проблему, яку ми бачимо
ось дозвольте мені перевірити, чи це працює, так, так
і яка позиція всередині
ну як усе це, тож у нас лише 6
відсоток населення світу, крім вас
мають 25 відсотків усіх високоякісних
наукові публікації так це дійсно
цікаво, але є одна проблема, яка
схоже на те, що у вас є бізнес
рнт інвестицій, які тоді не такі вже й високі
це в інших країнах, тому ми повинні
будьте також трохи відкритими щодо
комерційні або прикладні
проблеми, і тому ми також розглядаємо
Інновації та підприємництво та коли
ви подивіться в робочі програми і ми
прийде до терміну частіше ці
це опублікований курс, який ви знайдете
завжди
Інновація
підприємництво як певна конкурентоспроможність
сума ключових слів, тому мова йде про a
питання економічного зростання, так
не забувайте, що це навчання
який запитують, тож ви це бачили
малюнок, у вас є ці три ну як
у програмі Horizon Europe
і у вас там внизу ви
мають цю горизонтальну структуру
змінити проблеми, що впливають
гм, і все це йде з бюджетом
і це величезний бюджет, тому було
політичну угоду в грудні зберегти
цей бюджет дійсно довгий, але е-е
дійсно багато, але це розділено
кілька років і ви маєте ці
розділення також із дзвінками та
планування, щоб у вас не було жодного
виклик, який оголошено зараз або який є
працює відкрито, але є річна робота
програми, і ви можете нормально бачити
програма роботи на той рік, яка була
оголошено, я думаю, 16 червня
і наступний рік побачиш нормально
зазвичай це не змінюється, але ми цього не робимо
дивіться ще для 2023 24 25 627
так це може змінитися, але це ясно
ну яке бюджетне призначення
в межах усіх цих програм
коли ми дивимося на попередні програми
речі були вивчені, тому були
проміжна та проміжна оцінка 2020р
там була як пост-оцінка
попередник цього, який ви
побачив би як ліва рука і є
Уроки Вивчений один урок несловення Урок
Навчилися встановлювати як нові
підходить і по праву руку бачиш
кілька підходів, які були ніби вдосконалені
від поточної ситуації, і я буду
познайомити вас з цим трохи
га так так
так добре, що ми мали в Horizon
2020 та моніторингу
попередник попередник так у нас був
1,5 мільйона співробітництва зі 150
країн, включно з Україною
курс
у нас було як збільшення найкращих
Публікації, яка досі є однією з
основні результати дослідження
публікація
отже, ми також бачили
інвестиції, які прийшли з корейським
виклик, схожий на коронавірус
і ми бачили також інвестиції з
щодо зміни клімату
і так, те, що може бути добре чи ні, є
що ми отримали так багато пропозицій
але це показує великий інтерес, а також
необхідність такого проекту
добре, давайте продовжимо, тож насправді там
є кілька проблем, які пов’язані з
що стосується наступного Horizon Europe
ці три проблеми
амбіції є
прогресувати з науковою і
технологічна досконалість
другий — дивитися в зелений і
цифровий перехід
що там можна підтримувати, який має a
чіткий вплив на суспільство, а потім і на мене
сказав також це нововведення
конкурентоспроможність конкурентоспроможність і робочі місця
це важливий елемент створення
амбіції загальної програми так
коли ви пропонуєте профі з певним
тема пропозиція, тоді вам доведеться подумати
який твій внесок у це
до цих амбіцій
добре, і ми проходимо все це
uh uh порушують uh нові елементи
у нас є питання європейського
Рада інновацій, яка дивиться на
Проривна та руйнівна природа
Інвестиції та інновації
тож у вас є бюджет, який переважно становить
спрямовані на малий і середній бізнес
які також співпрацюють з дослідниками
а також використовувати приватне фінансування
розширити свої компанії та переїхати
вперед з уже розпочатими процесами
це питання, орієнтоване на інновації, і це
підтримує так, ніби змушує ризикувати
легше і допомагає
знизу вгору
розвитку
які надходять від самих компаній
а у вас є ще й європеєць
Рада інновацій
менеджери програм, які підтримують розвиток
бачення та трохи керувати своїми портфоліо
тому також є трохи впливу
ту сторону
і насправді їх три
є важливі інструменти
Pathfinder з ранніми технологіями
питань і що перехід, де ви
також уже є як a
докомерційна концепція, і ви хочете
щоб розвинути це трохи далі
а потім акселератор, який дивиться
кращі інвестиції
у стартапах і малих підприємствах, тож для деяких із вас
це буде актуально
ви маєте як другий компонент
місії
так що у вас є портфоліо
дії, які приходять з повагою
вимірна мета
отже, це місія
певна мета, яку потрібно досягти з суспільством
вплив, це як сама проблема і
у вас є п'ять охоплених місій
щодо The Horizon Europe так ці
є зонами місії, де вони були
виявлено ще багато областей
які були запропоновані, але це те
ті, які пропонуються та дотримуються
момент, щоб ви побачили всі ядра
які пов’язані з цими сферами Місії
тож якщо ви працюєте в одному з них
поля
більш-менш ближче, ніж ви можете
очікуйте, що дзвінки будуть оголошені
знайти теми
на тому
тож ви бачите, що є зміна клімату
який довго обговорюється та
соціальна трансформація, пов'язана, отже, як a
найбільше неінфекційне захворювання
проблеми зі здоров'ям, які у вас є
також питання води та внутрішніх і
океани цього у вас є клімат
нейтральні розумні міста, і ви також маєте
це ті більш сільські проблеми ґрунту
здоров'я та продукти харчування, а також біорізноманіття
зайшов сюди, тож це було схоже на зроблене
з пропозиціями так було багато
було відібрано п’ять пропозицій
вставте сюди, ви бачите, що це перші
два
є інші три, які вони мають
певний титул, який вони мають, і вони
також є певна подібна дія
поля, які накладають на uh
дотримуватися цього стратегічного підходу та
створити певний вплив, ніж щодо
сьогодні
тоді ми маємо Європейське партнерство
який є наступним елементом, який ви знайдете тут
Європейське партнерство схоже
Партнерство, яке приходить
разом із країнами-членами, але
також асоційовані країни
є різновидом спільного програмування того, що є
важливі питання для вирішення, і якщо ви
подивіться, у вас було багато кандидатів
і я думаю, що зараз у нас 11
ми як дуже важливі, які
підтримуються в першому турі, але
це також як нова інформація в
з останнього
минулого тижня, тому ми маємо це
Партнерства Партнерства приходять як
тобто інституційні партнерства
є навіть закон європейський як
це може працювати, а також є підтримка
тож це стратегічне партнерство
зазвичай це багато мільйонів євро
народжень і вони мають свої робочі
програму та власні цілі до
сприяти
і так, є веб-сторінка, де ви
можна зачепити це навіть прес є
оголошення вибраного
Партнерство, яке триває, але це також a
політично порядок денний і політично
активні, які стоять позаду, тому я
маються на увазі вболівальники з членів ЄС
країни, для яких вони також повинні бути співзасновниками
Наприклад, інвестування Партнерства
і є як зобов'язання
певні організації, які їх вносять
тому він не фінансується окремо
бюджет ЄС
коли ви дивитеся в міжнар
співробітництва, що він сьогодні вже чув
є асоціація
тож у вас відмінний успіх
The Horizon 2020, а й від неї
попередня програма, тож так
є процес асоціації, який
схоже, що це включає багато країн
програма
гм є також цілеспрямовані дії, які
щоб підтримати це я повідомлю в кінці
дня або про ті
і що важливо, багато з
оголошені дзвінки запитує
участь країн, що прибувають з
скажімо, за кордоном, але також звідти
асоційованих країн, тому існує a
мотивація для координатора
що походить, можливо, від a з
Нідерланди Італія Австрія або де завгодно
Німеччина також залучає
Україна, і це насправді хороший знак
тому є потреба задовольнити це
Міжнародна співпраця uh Challenge
і це вважається суспільством
виклик
добре, що у вас є відкрита наука
чули про відкриті наукові журнали
ви чули про обмін дослідженнями
результати
так, це є певна практика
підтримується комісією так там
є відкритим доступом до публікації, яка
приходить які походять від спільної праці в
фінансуються проекти, тому має бути відкритий
доступ до публікації, але також є
кілька умовних частин, які надходять
з пропозицією, як ви повинні мати a
план управління даними, тому це дає a
також є підказка, як це приготувати
Європейська хмара відкритої науки, що
означає, де наука практикує, але також
Публікації доступні є
також може бути дискусія з цього приводу
гм так, а також є відкритий
дослідження євро видавнича платформа, яка
полегшує публікацію, а особливо
використання результатів ЄС
фінансовані дослідження
все ж таки є ризик
проект ефірних програм і це як
що дослідник дає так
дослідник також надає цей доступ
інші з ду круті, ніж у вас
також інші інструменти, які добре
пов’язаний із Horizon Europe This is
вартість
коштує як найстаріший
інструмент um Corporation по всій Європі
і він також є активним у всьому світі
вартість дій, які виглядають на досконалість
і співпраця
тож у вас є декілька можливостей
у коді ви також маєте вартість NCP
Україна, наскільки я пам'ятаю, так у вас
Ці можливості надаються вартістю
є мережі, які вони підтримують, і це
неймовірно важливий як засіб відкривання дверей
майбутнім дружинам так, тому що це a
тематичних мереж і ви можете оцінити
тоді ви зможете отримати доступ до простіших мереж
які вже працюють у полі
гм так, ви також бачите тут багато багато
проблеми, де фактично приходить вартість
угорі внизу ви бачите це тут
який також є на цій картинці
він також є співзасновником громадянських прав у
Європа так
ну так, як ти можеш брати участь?
насправді це два шляхи
є фінансування для фізичних осіб
дослідники
найважливіше для докторів наук, але також
просунутих підрахунок повідомить вам
про дії, пов'язані з тим і
у вас також є спільне дослідження
де ви повинні мати три сутності
які співпрацюють принаймні з однією істотою
з країни-члена та за її межами
може бути така асоційована країна, як
українське майбутнє
і йому також потрібен третій
і вони повинні бути з трьох різних
країн, тому це як мінімум
хвороба
Я ніколи не бачив пропозиції позитивно
оцінюється з трьома країнами так
зазвичай це починається з п'яти країн
я маю на увазі насправді, але це трапляється, так
тому є деякі дзвінки, але це
дійсно мінімальна умова і це
це використовується так, як якщо є
конкретна підтримка, яка також в
Реакція Марії на одяг
ви почуєте про це так, але
зазвичай у вас є консорціуми
Тематичний стовп 2, який можна розмістити
до 40 50 партнерів, тож це діапазон
ви можете знайти, і тоді це дійсно
також важко позиціонувати та входити
такі конструкції
і ви також почуєте на
індивідуальні можливості так детально так
у вас також є синергія з іншими
Профспілкові програми, щоб ви побачили
Horizon Europe на вершині, але у вас є
також під цим багато програм
які приходять сюди для деяких ви
придатні для деяких ні
тож там, де ви, є кілька
відповідає вимогам, і тут є Синергія
має бути узгодженістю та взаємодоповнюваністю
і має бути також Фінансовий
взаємодоповнюваність у спосіб
це співзасновництво або об’єднання ресурсів
досить складний і раджу подивитися
спільно з НКП у цих питаннях якщо
ви натрапляєте на пошук
добре, ми пояснили вам, що це
це структура, тому у вас є три
стовпи, і у вас є внизу це
горизонтальні заходи
це дуже схоже на огляд і
якщо ви подивіться на перший стовп і
ресурси упаковані так стрибають знову
тут у нас чудовий стовп один
наука з трьома сферами дії ви
фактично цей перший стовп
Європейська дослідницька рада
який фінансує найкращих дослідників вас
мають різні гловеські реакції
де ви дивитесь на знання дослідників
та Навички з мобільністю та навчанням
і дослідницькі інфраструктури, щоб ви
бачите, що там багато грошей
перші два, але не так багато в
дослідницькі інфраструктури, тому що
дослідницькі інфраструктури приходять трохи
окремо ви побачите є є
стратегічне планування на європейському рівні
і є певний список, який також є
розширений, але це дуже
складний процес, це нелегко зробити
знайдіть свій вхід там, але він є
можливі також партнерства існують
ось так це перший стовп і
бачите, грошей багато
який доступний
добре, і питання в тому, де ви знайдете
для першого випуску у фінансуванні для
індивідуальне дослідження, ви знайдете це насправді
у грантах Європейської дослідницької ради
але також і в другому Марія
Прокручує кулінарні дії, які ви отримаєте
більше інформації згодом там
добре, коли ми приходимо сюди з дослідженням
Рад у вас насправді чотири різних
гранти
які всі йдуть до PhD
Консолідований грант знову PhD і
у вас є розширені гранти та гранти Synergy
який для більш просунутих
гм, ви почуєте про це пізніше
але просто сказати вам, що є
різні цільові
ну
можливості, які також мають свої
специфіка
щоб ввести їх
коли ми дивимося на другий стовп це
знаходиться в середині цієї довжини
фото, у вас багато ресурсів
припарковано це більше половини
ресурси, припарковані в horizon horizon
Європа
це пов’язано з глобальними викликами
і ми маємо шість глобальних проблем, які
включені сюди
і вони постачаються з цими шістьма кластерами
ці шість кластерів також присутні
в робочій програмі
тому програма роботи, оголошена 16 числа
Червень містить для кожного з цих малюнків
з цих кіл ви бачите тут певний
визначення акордів, тому є там
є опис того, що є
вміст щодо здоров'я для
екземпляр дивлячись на перший так там
це
запитання зверху вниз, щоб відповісти на конкретний
проблеми та виклики в охороні здоров'я
світ
і те саме повторюється з усім тим і
це документ кількох сотень
Сторінки, які сповіщають про ці дзвінки нормально
це кілька сторінок на тему
але не здоров'я одна тема а це
має близько 50 оголошених тем
за цей дворічний період
так що ось ви бачите так званий
кластери, які були такими
круглі кола, ось це у вас є
квадратів і знайти ви також знайдете тут
гроші, які доступні щодо
конкретні виклики
ви можете отримати доступ, і це коди
хоча вам потрібно знати, щоб знайти
виклик анонсованих тем тут
до останнього стовпа, якщо ви пам'ятаєте
у нас було три стовпи Досконалість
ці кластери ви бачили зараз і зараз
у нас є інноваційна Європа
мають так звані європейські інновації
Рада, яка дивиться на нововведення
тоді у вас також є певний uh
певне поле, яке виглядає на
Інноваційні екосистеми так не на самому
Самі інновації, але в екосистемі
що підтримує інновації
і у вас там величезний бюджет
тож у вас також є кошти для відновлення
внутрішнє відновлення після коронакризи
і праворуч є окремий
руку, яка називається Європейський інститут
інновацій і технологій, які мають
окреме фінансування та мережа
можливості, які не виглядають
подивився тут, але теж цікаво
оскільки має певну
гм тематичний напрямок
тим, хто на самому дні
картина, до якої ви приходите, розширюється
участь і зміцнення в
Європейський дослідницький простір так звані Філдс
у вас насправді два різних один
це те, що ви тут бачите
um дивідендна участь teaming
Twinning error стільці і все це
питань
гм, а у вас майже 3 мільярди євро
і в правій руці ви бачите це там
є конкретні дії, які також
сприяння реструктуризації наукової сфери
гм, які постачаються з відео з високим вмістом жиру
добре, і тут ви також знайдете проблему
Стратегічний план
гм, який постачається разом із Moto and
багаторічний стратегічний план, тобто
готові на рівні ЄС допомогти всім цим
питання, які мають бути реалізовані
також із дискретною стратегічною орієнтацією
за підтримку
і європейське партнерство, але також
місії та
Міжнародне співробітництво ми в
перший стратегічний план охоплює три
років або фактично чотири роки
хм, і це було наче спільно розроблено
Європейська комісія з членом
держав і Європейського парламенту
і так, такі були
рішення
і це було прийнято в березні, що так
тому ми повинні були знайти ці рішення
також тоді в цілому в Обрії
ваші робочі програми, які ви бачили, ми маємо
ці компоненти, тому ми маємо це
стовпи ви бачили ці три
стовпи я пояснив і нарешті
при поєднанні всіх цих тем, які є
у цих трьох стовпах, до яких ви прийшли
певні частини
певні частини, які складаються з ан
вступ, що пояснює все те, що я
покажу тобі зараз
Крім того, це дуже робочі програми
і, можливо, італієць, який ви могли б
розмістити посилання на фінансування та тендер
портал, щоб побачити також ці робочі програми I
знайте, що у вас дуже хороший слайд
показуючи все це, як до нього можна отримати доступ
Отже, у вас є 11 частин, які покривають
фактично всі розмірні теми
але ви повинні мати на увазі, що там
це три стовпи і де ви
і які амбіції
і цільові цілі в цих стовпах
так
але тоді у вас окрема робота
програми, які виглядають по-європейськи
науково-дослідної ради, а також шукайте
спільний дослідницький центр і The Innovation
Рада також Європейський інститут
Технологія є взаємодоповнювальною, але
інтегрований
а є й інші
тісно пов'язані питання
якщо ви пам'ятаєте на першому слайді
Я вам показав всю групу «Горизонт».
зображення з того боку, яке ви бачили ліворуч
і фонд оборони і праворуч
рука оратора
так що вони також сильно інтернет
взаємопов'язані
хм, але це насправді те
питання, яке також зустрічається з іншими
програм і це в усьому Обрії
Європа також пов’язана з багатьма
інші програми ЄС
добре виглядають бенефіціари
або з тієї точки зору, яку ви маєте
насправді
більш-менш фінансування Horizon 2020
Оцініть ставки, які ви також застосували
Горизонт Європа
існує єдиний набір правил
це документ про сотенний платіж
сотні сторінок, які можуть дати вам
інформація про прийнятність витрат
реалізація проекту
а також, як е-е, скасування цього
і як розраховується фінансування
коли ви робите пропозицію
[Музика]
питання завжди в тому, як ти е-е
якщо у вас є витрати, як ви можете повідомити
їх і що фінансується
це знову звичайний облік витрат
практики, що означає, що ви не можете
встановити конкретну роль для конкретного
програму у вашій організації, щоб ви
не бачать у Horizon Europe наші погодинні
ставки денні ставки такі ж високі, як це
має бути єдиним правилом для всього
Заклад для всіх програм, які ви
брати участь
але є ширше визнання
фінансові установи можуть повідомити про це
як з цим працювати і якщо
ви перевищили певний поріг
фінансування, і ви дійсно його споживаєте
фінансування перевищує певний поріг
Ви повинні провести обов'язковий аудит і
є поріг, який теж був
збільшився
в підготовці
може бути одна проблема, яка навіть
важливіше сама зосередженість на впливах
так
на самому етапі подання заявки
вже потрібно визначити вздовж впливу
Шляхи вашого впливу
ви також повинні мати
демонстрація синергії з іншими проектами
і подібні речі, але у вас також є
у реалізації цієї синергії
з іншими програмами фінансування, щоб вони
може бути в дзвінку е-е
рядок, написаний синергією з іншими
Програми фінансування відповідають бажанню
дзвінок, тому інший партнер повинен
знайти синергію та дізнатися, як це можна зробити
бути реалізованим
так і знову тут ви знову все бачите
ці інші програми Союзу, де ви можете
можливо, знайти синергію
гм, їх багато хто міг би
як приклад є
інвестування в дослідження та інновації
який знаходиться на додатковій схемі Beyond
Горизонт Європа
це має ефект важеля
надає гарантії в більшості випадків так
це важливо для приватного сектору
та інвестиції, але як випливає з назви
це не для дослідження, але воно поєднується
ця конкурентоспроможність Інновації та
такі питання та розвиток компанії
і тут ми маємо ключовий вплив
Шляхи визначає сама програма
ключових впливів, які мають відношення до
науковий вплив соціальний вплив для
економічний ефект і фактично є
є дев'ять впливів
і в кожній поданій пропозиції
ці впливи мають бути прояснені та
детально описано
Отже, ви бачите перші три кампус
знання людський капітал, але також
поширення знань, тому це не те
типовий вплив публікації, але це
йде набагато далі, це йде до знань
людський капітал, а також цю відданість
проблема, коли ви дивитесь на другий соц
вплив, оскільки це також схоже на низхідний
програма в багатьох питаннях у вас є це
політичні пріоритети та завдання
мати
переваг і впливу, але ви також маєте
сприйняття в суспільстві як соц
вплив, і ви повинні описати те, що є
ваш соціальний вплив
і нарешті, що можливо в деяких випадках
найважливішим є економічний
вплив, яке приносить ці сувої
що базується на знаннях і
Інноваційне створення, але також і
залучення інвестицій від приватних
сектора чи від громадськості
інший шлях
тож у вас є ці три впливи та дев’ять
вплив Pathways незалежно від того, хто відвідує
пропозицію Camp потім можна почути більше про
що можуть бути впливи тощо
Ви можете зробити багато презентацій
вже знайте, як це має бути
структурований і так далі, хто цим керує
означає так, вибачте, що перебили нас
треба стежити за часом, добре
у нас, я думаю, два три слайди добре
тоді ми в порядку
добре гм
проблема в тому, що сама програма
дивиться також на шляхи впливу
тому що він збирає все це
проекти сприяють
і це виглядає тоді щодо всього цього
проблеми, і тому ця структура є
слідувати
і тут у вас є кілька балів
вказівок, як це можна подумати
гм
так
це надто складно, можливо, я хочу
зробити це
іноземні
добре, як це прийшло до Horizon
Європа та ця поточна робоча програма
зараз, можливо, 10 днів тому
так що було як підготовка a
стратегічний план, який був як a
спільне створення е-е-е обличчя також у трьох
років трохи викликано
вже в короні
а потім у нас був цей стратегічний план і
робоча програма, тому ці 11
робочі програми плюс додатки mix 12
плюс введення суміші певних так
у нас така програма роботи на два роки
і це було прийнято зараз, і тому ви
отримувати дійсно свіжу інформацію
це не виклик, який був запущений
раніше, але є велика частина як a
рекомендація, коли ви чуєте, що
Комісія готує програму роботи
і ви вже знаєте, що в
2022 їм видадуть ще одну роботу
програма на наступні роки після 20
22, то тут вже можна знайти чернетки
тому вам доведеться шукати чернетки
яка сфера для вас цікава
і добре, якщо ти навіть стрибаєш
дані в одному з дзвінків — це добре
це вже можна подивитися що було
підтримується і хто активний і хто
можна заскочити в тему, але це можна
також виконайте з попередньою програмою
можете подивитися, хто фінансувався у вашій темі
а потім заскочити
і я маю на увазі підійти до них і запитати, чи
Ви також можете внести певний внесок
родичі на тому бо
так
добре, що є багато способів слідувати
події
ось кілька веб-сторінок, які ви отримаєте
їх презентації пізніше, щоб ви
можна заглянути, але пам’ятайте, що
Сайт Horizon Europe, мабуть, головний
головне важливе це тут, у
середній, але ви знайдете його відразу або
з вашою пошуковою системою, тому це не так
повністю складний, але також
викладач дослідження та інновації Facebook
дуже цікаво, тому що пост
про найновіші події далі
можливості для участі та як це
все онлайн на даний момент або в
найменше Blended це дуже легко для вас
спробуйте, і вам не потрібно буде подорожувати
витрати тут там ви можете просто приєднатися і
отримати найкращу інформацію, тому це, можливо, a
невелике покращення через кризу
це все ще триває, тому так, е-е, тут більше
на амбіції
також впливу
Інноваційний потенціал а також с
цей екран і цифровий перехід і
Стягнення питання так комісіонера є
дуже активний у цьому і хоче поставити
що далі ми маємо цю електронну адресу
ви також знайдете його на сторінці, де ви
зареєстровано, щоб ви могли публікувати все
Питання пізніше будуть конкретними
просили підтримки, це також добре, я
означає підтримку в значенні
um підтримка для консультацій пізніше
на так що це як перша частина
вступ, я впевнений, що все інше
частини цікавіші, тому що вони
більш конкретні, але якщо ви не знаєте
три стовпи, можливо, це важко зробити
розуміти вбудованість
дуже інформації, яку ви отримаєте в наступному
презентації та і години так гм Віталій
насправді ми можемо перемістити індекс
Справедливість і місії негайно так в
стовп теж так, але я пропоную ми
спочатку дайте відповідь на питання, які у нас є
отримано через чат є один
особливе рівняння для вас
Фелікс, ну, від Олександра, ти можеш побачити
запитайте себе, це о 11 31
чи я прочитаю це
Я можу це прочитати, добре
отже, ситуація така, що ви подали заявку
для фінансування в зміїному суді, якщо я
правильно зрозумів і так воно і було
недостатньо добре
бути оціненим для фінансування так, ви можете
потрапити в резервний список, якщо ні
мати достатньо балів, які можна отримати, як е-е
взагалі не вище Порогу, якщо є
це як один ish недостатньо добре, якщо ви
мати недостатньо хороших балів
ну тоді у вас є така пропозиція
або не вистачає фінансування і вони
вирішуйте, незважаючи на те, що у вас є 15 балів
вирішити не фінансувати свій
так гм
добре, тому ви отримуєте 10 від
надіслати лист про відмову
та підсумковий звіт про оцінку
в цих оціночних документах, оскільки в
підсумковий звіт про оцінку, який є a
написаний tether ви не бачите лише точки
ти не бачиш сенсу на відмінно
вплив і впровадження, яке ви бачите
також описова частина, яка розповідає вам
що було хорошого в пропозиції і що
було не так добре відповідно до
оцінювачі, ви можете не погодитися, але все ж
це рішення так
і саме тут ви можете навчитися
тому що ви бачите тепер добре є
перспективу, яку намалювали кілька
оцінювачі це зведено в текст
це підсумковий звіт про оцінку
і там можна визначити те, чого не було
що було недосконалим
так приємно вчитися на цьому, але я це серйозно
вам ще не допомагає, тому ви подали заявку
для певної теми ціла тема, що
було оголошено
гм, а тепер ти стоїш там добре
ви хочете використовувати його повторно, тому вам доведеться шукати
в робочій програмі якщо щось є
це як пов'язано з ним і як ви
були в консорціумі, це найкраще
написати листа своєму я маю на увазі
електронною поштою своєму попередньому координатору або
основні партнери, де ви маєте
ніби розвинув певний Траст
і запитайте, чи варто обговорювати в an
онлайн-обговорення, що могло б бути
точки, які можна переробити та далі
використовується в поточних викликах
ой, що краще не зберігати
що схоже на те, щоб зробити на додачу, ну
так і в темах теж можна подивитися
ну в попередньому дзвінку, хто був
фінансується і що фінансується, щоб ви
побачити різницю з вашим профілем
головоломка, можливо, вона була занадто складною чи ні
до речі, можливо, це було востаннє
днів зусиль, тому що приготування до
Я маю на увазі, що заявки зазвичай займають місяці
не вашого часу, а тривалості
цей процес цього місяця, тому, коли ви
підхід зараз до деяких колег це дуже
хороший момент часу, тому що тоді настає
літо, що дуже складно і
дедлайни більшість дедлайнів
Вересень і жовтень не тільки
але більшість термінів припадає на вересень і
Жовтень, так що це буде як моя відповідь
сподіваюся, це допоможе
бачиш, я думаю, велике спасибі, Фелікс
у нас не залишилося питань, ось чому
о так, що якби не було оцінки
резюме, але це так цікаво
то або ви його не подали
тому координатор не подав би
здивуй мене
або контактна особа ні
відповідно вказано, тому перейдіть у
фінансування та тендерний портал, де у вас є
застосована це електронна система, де
заявки повинні бути виконані
а потім перейти до поданих пропозицій
де ви брали участь до
ви знайдете пакет документів
а може координатор повинен
розповсюджувати, я не знаю, можливо, це
як це, тому, можливо, дозвольте мені запитати
твій координатор, тому що е-е, це справа
їм роздати все своє
документація для бенефіціарів
але будівництва так ви
правильно, але він зберігається в Інтернеті, так
ти координатор добре
кожного учасника я знаю я знаю але
іноді є деякі технічні е-е
труднощі це мій досвід
принаймні, але Соломонія каже, що вона сама
координатор, тому я не впевнений, що це
що там сталося ви все ще можете
зверніться до свого керівника проекту або контакт
гм, можливо, це було б не трохи дешевше, якби
воно не було прийнятним, тому що ви цього не зробили
тримати все добре
добре, але я маю лише оцінку erl
результати який список що що таке ера L I
знаю, я не впевнений ні, я цього не знаю
можливо це це свого роду a
так
добре схожий документ добре
добре, але якщо у вас є, можливо, так і було
помилка, але вони можуть виглядати, а я можу
скласти підсумковий звіт про оцінку та
покажу тобі, як це виглядає, можливо, я зможу
поділитися ним з вами після Італії після вашого
презентація. Я можу просто поділитися одним, я хочу
приготуйте один добре, впевнений, що це чудово для
моя вдала пропозиція Можливо
Гаразд
добре, ти ведучий, тепер я
ведучий правильно я бачу
так, добре, так MIA ми переїжджаємо
вперед до другого стовпа
і давай я шукаю
на той час добре по-перше
гм
перш за все дозвольте мені лише один раз підкреслити
знову те, що представник в
Українське міністерство uh сказало, що Україна
буде пов’язано з Horizon
Європа, а це означає, що ти будеш
розглядатися як держава-член
ти так будеш мати як Україна така ж
права та однакові обов'язки
хм, я хотів би наголосити на цьому
тому що питань було багато
посилаючись на цей аспект так як an
Ви як би асоційована країна
привілейовані ви маєте однакові права і
однакові зобов'язання
наступного разу я вимкну камеру
щоб уникнути будь-яких можливих технічних
питань
перевага для вас полягає в тому, що ви будете
можливість повністю зосередитися на змісті
моя презентація так вже Фелікс
розповів вам про те, як ви можете взяти участь
у спільному проекті
і тут мова йде особливо про
дилер 2 і знову як сутність
ви з асоційованої країни
однакове ставлення до держави-члена та
гм
важливо те, що Джулія сказала
представник вашого міністерства, що
очікується, що угода про асоціацію буде
підписано, ймовірно, у жовтні або о
принаймні до кінця 2021 року
це означає, що ви маєте право на це
подайте заявку прямо зараз
лише в момент часу, е-е-е, як
ну грантова угода буде
підписаний ви повинні бути пов'язані, тому ви
вже зараз мають право взяти участь
у всіх дзвінках
хм, щоб заощадити час, я не буду говорити
про партнера по міжнародній співпраці
країни, а не про країни БРІКС
тому що це не стосується України
тут важливим є правило, викладене на
дно, якого ми зазвичай маємо дотримуватися
це загальне правило для всіх спільних
проекти це означає три з трьох так як
мінімальна вимога, як сказав Фелікс
має бути консорціумом із трьох осіб
суб'єкти-учасники
з різних країн-членів ЄС або
Асоційовані країни та принаймні одна з
ці організації повинні бути державою-членом
це знову ж таки це мінімум
стан, як правило, такі консорціуми
більші, наприклад, для Mariscos
реакції uh комісія рекомендує
консультації від 6 до 10 до 12
можливо Партнери це середнє значення
розмір такого консорціуму
ну це список
країни-учасниці Horizon
Європа. Я розмістив це посилання на
чат також ось як ви можете знайти
вся ця документація, яка є
важливі для процесу подання заявки
отже, у цьому списку є гіперпосилання
країн-учасниць, тож якщо ви
отримайте цю презентацію пізніше
можна просто натиснути на це гіперпосилання та отримати
це там, але в основному я пояснив
зі знімками екрана ви переходите до
фінансування порталів можливостей претендента
ви клацаєте це головне меню як
участь, а потім посилання на меню
документів і там ви берете програмування
період з 21 по 27 і тоді ви знайдете
у довідковому документі все
необхідні документи, і ви бачите, що в
список країн-учасниць
Україна входить до числа третіх країн
Пов’язаний з Horizon Europe і я сподіваюся
ви можете побачити це на цьому скріншоті
Україна є однією з цих 17 країн
список
і наступне запитання, це було
висловив у чаті, де знайти
знову такі спільні дзвінки
ваша відправна точка завжди е
портал фінансування та тендерних можливостей
і ви бачите пошук у верхньому меню
претенденти на фінансування ось де ви
приступити до пошуку відповідного
дзвінки, і ви бачите, що я зараз фільтрую
два стовпи Глобальні виклики та
Європейська промислова конкурентоспроможність немає
тут зазначено шість кластерів
ліворуч і праворуч можна побачити a
один чи два тут конкретні виклики
вже відкриті для подання, і ви
можна, якщо ти натиснеш на цей виклик, ти зможеш
знайти всю документацію щодо
ця конкретна роль
ми знову тут, у стовпі
Глобальні виклики та європейські
промислової конкурентоспроможності, і ми маємо
ну, тут перелічено шість кластерів, я ні
збираюся прочитати вголос це ще раз, але це
в основному ваша робота це те, що я сказав
над чатом це, е-е, свого роду
загальний опис кластера але
Звичайно, буде багато дзвінків
у цьому конкретному кластері у вашому
завдання полягатиме в ідентифікації кластера на a
дзвоніть у цьому кластері, куди б ви хотіли
як застосувати або
це знову пояснення цього
кластер, тож це знову ж таки загальне
мета цього кластера, щоб ми були здорові
мати культурну творчість та інклюзивність
суспільства, для яких ми маємо цивільну безпеку
суспільство цифрова індустрія та космос
кліматична енергія та мобільність харчування
біоекономіка природні ресурси Сільське господарство
і середовище, як ви бачите, це широке
тем і в межах цих тем ви будете
знайти дзвінки, які можуть бути цікаві для
ваш заклад і ви бачите бюджет
цих кластерів
тепер ну ти ну ти бачив на
попередній Слайд загального бюджету, що
тепер у вас є бюджет на
кластер це може бути цікаво
Ну
гм, щоб заощадити час на просування вперед
тож тепер це пояснення для
один кластер Здоров'я, отже, це е-е
список тем, якими ви зазвичай займаєтеся
у цьому кластері, і ось де
ви можете знайти дзвінки, що стосуються цього
конкретна тема, так як ух
неінфекційні непрочитані захворювання
інфекційні захворювання, включаючи бідність
пов'язані та знехтувані це і так далі
і так далі, тому в основному ви просто е-м
прочитайте ці теми та визначте тему
що цікаво для вашого закладу
і тоді ви можете
спробуйте потрапити в консультацію для
приклад подання заявки на фінансування
Я просто переглядаю чат
звичайно, Олександр
також запрошуються невеликі компанії, середні та середні підприємства
брати участь, як я вже сказав
Горизонт Європа про
це рамкова програма для
дослідження та інновації, і якщо ваше МСП
займається дослідженнями та інноваціями
заходи, звичайно, ви можете
брати участь, навіть, навіть, я маю на увазі, що це так
навіть велика перевага брати участь як
заклад з неакадем
сектор, тому що ну європейський
Комісія розуміє необхідність
бути мобільним з точки зору фізичної мобільності
між країнами, а й з точки зору
мобільний між секторами академічний і
неакадемічний сектор та молодь
вчені повинні зібратися
досвід також у неакадем
секторі та навчилися тих
продажі певних навичок
важливі для неакадемічного сектору
тому що передісторією є те, що всі ми
знаю, що тільки маленький
відсоток усіх молодих постдоків
наприклад, може залишитися в академічному
більшість із них потрібно знайти
це робота в неакадемічній сфері
навіщо брати участь у компанії
бути чудовою річчю, але принаймні ви повинні
брати участь у дослідженнях та інноваціях
діяльності
знову ж таки, це приклад кластера
культуротворчість та інклюзивне суспільство
знову це стосується створення
щодо бібліотеки, яку я отримав
чат, наприклад, чи можна вам фінансувати
як наукова бібліотека, звичайно, але
можливо, ви можете поєднати це, знаєте
знову the
комісія проводить розшук
потрійний підходжу до Міжнар
міждисциплінарний сектор і, можливо, ви
може знайти рішення для вашого наукового
Бібліотека, як оцифрувати свій um
наші ресурси там, і, можливо, це може
бути цікавою пропозицією
з цією темою, і це було б
спосіб, як ви могли, як ви можете отримати
наприклад, фінансується в рамках цього кластера
це кластер три
громадянська безпека для суспільства ви знаєте і
сьогодні цивільна безпека не дуже
важка тема і, звичайно, європейська
Комісія інвестує багато uh
часу, грошей і зусиль для того, щоб
покращити особливо кібербезпеку, тому якщо
ви активні в цій сфері це буде
бути правильним кластером для вас
тут для дзвінка
кластер 4 стосується цифрових технологій
промисловість і космос знову це
список тем
гм, від вас очікують
справа в цьому кластері і знову якщо
Ви тут активні, ласкаво просимо
визначити виклик і подати заявку
у цьому кластері займається кластер 5
знову з кліматичною енергією та мобільністю a
дуже гаряча тема, про яку ми всі знаємо
зміни клімату, про які ми всі знаємо
енергетичне питання, про яке ми всі знаємо
проблема мобільності, і це знову де a
багато грошей інвестується з
Європейського Союзу, а й до речі
приватні компанії, які намагаються створити
наприклад
електронна мобільність і так далі і тому подібне, якщо
ви активні в цій сфері ви дуже
Ласкаво просимо визначити виклик у цьому
кластер
і ну
так, вибачте, останнє, але не менш важливе
це шостий кластер
про харчування біоекономіки та натуральн
ресурси Сільське господарство та навколишнє середовище I
думаю, що це також важлива тема
для України, тому що Україна важлива
сільське господарство країни і, звичайно, якщо
ви активні тут, у цій сфері ви це
це правильний кластер для вас
тому я шукаю
знову в чаті
добре, дякую, Фелікс
гм
так що
звичайно
гм
Заявлено міжнародну участь
тут розглядається в численних темах і
гм
ці теми
насправді
гм
в основному це важливо для вас
прочитайте документацію для цього
особливий виклик, тому що все, що
очікується комісія буде
зазначено тут і
гм
хм, ви знайдете це в
опис дзвінка так воно і є
моя порада уважно прочитати
документації та дізнайтеся, що таке
очікування європейського uh
комісія, коли вона випускає це
наприклад, конкретний дзвінок
зараз це важливо, ну, щодо
фінансування, тому ми маємо кілька основних правил і
якщо ти активний
або якщо ви подаєте заявку на дослідження та
Інноваційні дії закликають вас
відшкодовано 100 відсотків
ну в акціях інновацій це 70 фор
прибуткові організації, такі як компанії МСП
і так далі, але все одно 100
для некомерційної організації знову 70
для прибутку 100 для неприбутку
організації, і на вершині ви отримаєте uh
фіксована ставка 25 непрямих витрат
це в основному загальне
Основне правило щодо фінансових аспектів
тепер ви бачите
хм, країни-члени, в яких вони знаходяться на цій карті
світло-блакитний колір і пов'язаний з ним
країни
хм, тут вони сірого кольору, а ну
вони раніше були пов’язані з Horizon
2020, як ви знаєте, Horizon 2020 зараз
і комісія каже, що е-е
ті ж країни висловили свої
інтерес бути пов'язаним з Horizon
Європа також і переговори є
все ще триває, і Україна є однією з них
тих країн і як ви чули
і, як я вже згадував, ми очікуємо
угода про асоціацію, яка має бути підписана
кінець цього року, але ти є
має право брати участь зараз
це важливо для всіх відкритих дзвінків
хм на момент підписання
договір надання асоціації
підписана лише угода з Україною
одне маленьке зауваження щодо Швейцарії
ось така ситуація трошки
різні так
моя загальна порада завжди буде такою
якщо ви створюєте консорціум, формуйте його так, як це потрібно
що цей Консорціум може існувати, навіть якщо
один партнер у загрозі і в цьому
наприклад, Швейцарія
тому що Швейцарія відмовилася
загальної згоди з європ
Союз так ось чому асоціація
Швейцарії, напевно, буде важко
отже, сформуйте консорціум таким чином
якщо цей партнер під загрозою не вміє
беріть участь через право
проблеми, які Консорціум все ще може вирішити
працювати, тому це дуже важливо для мене
переглянути
і знову ну
всі країни-члени всі асоційовані
до країн ставляться однаково, і вони
автоматично фінансуються, і я
посилається на список країн uh в
основна програма є список
країни, які також можуть отримати
фінансування Європейської комісії
в основному вони менш розвинені
країн і, звичайно, Європи
комісія не збирається фінансувати
країни з високим доходом
а щодо оцінювання їх три
критерії оцінки Excellence impact
і реалізація це те, що Фелікс
вже говорив про
гм, це знову слайд із
знову робочі програми в Horizon Europe
у вас був цей початковий слайд, а тепер ви
мати цей повний список усіх основних робіт
програми, які ви знаєте, ви бачите заг
вступ Mariscos узгодити дії
дослідницька інфраструктура, а потім здоров’я
і всі згадані тут Кластери
програми роботи вже були
опубліковані, ви можете знайти їх на
портал пошуку та тендерних можливостей
і я рекомендую завантажити їх і
уважно прочитавши їх, ви маєте тут
це Перетягніть гіперпосилання на це е-е-е
веб-сайт пошуку призначений
портал можливостей, і ви будете
здатний безпосередньо перейти до цього
презентація
і це лише для того, щоб надати вам
приклад, як знову виглядає такий дзвінок
є гіперпосилання на робочу програму
здоров'я кластера, і ось як
робоча програма виглядає так, отже, це a
ідентифікатор виклику та цей конкретний виклик
ви знайдете опис
ну що таке Європейська комісія
очікуючи цього конкретного дзвінка
хм знову це а
призначення один, наприклад це
призначення третє, і ви знову це бачите
надмірна тема, наприклад, тут
боротьби з хворобами та зменшення захворювань
знову тягар
відсортовано за цими темами та вашою роботою
полягає в тому, щоб визначити назву теми і
дзвінок, який стосується вашого
заклад, якщо ви хочете
взяти участь у цьому конкретному
спільний проект
знову ж таки, це покупка, ну це
приклад для розблокування Destination 5
повний потенціал нових інструментів
Технології та цифрові рішення для
Знову здорове суспільство
уважно підійдіть до опису цього
тема ну і опис
подзвоніть і визначте відповідний дзвінок
ти повинен
а це ух наприклад робота
програма uh про благородство кліматичної енергії
і ви бачите, що, наприклад, у цьому
робоча програма ви бачите дату відкриття
наприклад це
гм конкретні дзвінки або відкриті вчора
і гм
дата, коли дзвінки будуть закриті
приклад це ось вересень
14-й і ну
очікувана кількість проектів
фінансуватимуться вони також стандартні
як зазначено тут
і знову ж таки, це приклад цього
гм це список дзвінків у
кластер 5 кліматична енергія та мобільність
і
гм, я не збираюся розширювати лише тому, що ми
трохи відстають від часу
розклад
гм ще один приклад
з кластеру п'ять
і знову
гм
опис теми
ось як це виглядає
завантажте всю цю документацію, подивіться
уважно прочитайте опис і спробуйте
звернути увагу на кожну необхідну точку
для цього дзвінка
наприклад, це важливо
зрозуміти, який результат очікується
тому очікується внесок проектів
до наступних результатів і, звичайно
це залежить від вас, щоб вирішити всі ці питання
теми, згадані тут, це ваша робота
щоб створити цей очікуваний результат
і знову це опис
обсяг це те, що ви очікуєте
бути в рамках цього дзвінка знову ми
у рамках стовпа 2 ми переслідуємо a
на кшталт підходу «зверху вниз», у термінах
тем, комісія дає вам
ширше коло тем і ви
очікується, що ви придумаєте свою особистість
проект як консорціум, але ви є
очікується переміщення в цьому діапазоні
описано в дзвінку
тож лише 20
минуле так я думаю
ми непогані і я дивлюся на
чат, звичайно, ви можете зв'язатися з нами
ця електронна адреса
і я
думаю, Фелікс відповів на запитання
щодо СМС
чи є
інші будь-які інші питання
гм
знову вмикаю камеру
Велика Британія позначена як країна ЄС
у нас є колеги у Великій Британії
перспективи проектів з
колеги з Великобританії ух
Звичайно, Велика Британія не нова
країна більше це правильно
гм і
гм
але Великобританія, як очікується, буде повністю
Пов’язаний з Horizon Europe і um
переговори ще тривають і знову
як для України, вони мають право
застосувати uh з uh
умова, що в момент часу, коли
має бути підписаний земельний договір
ну ці угоди про асоціацію мають бути
укладений
тому я сподіваюся, що зможу відповісти на ваше запитання
гм
Я був о, так, дякую, дякую
Український державний університет ти вільний
з транспортом
дорогі друзі шановні колеги ну шановні
господарі дякують за презентацію
і можу я запитати вас, чи ви йдете
Я маю на увазі ваших організаторів загалом
чи збираєшся ти нам допомогти
Українські університети мають розвиватися
наш досвід у цій сфері, тому що ми
страждати від відсутності досвіду, як
застосувати, як керувати всіма цими процесами
Дайте відповіді на
дякую, дякую за це запитання
але це те, що я написав у
чат, тому що зазвичай процедура є
люблю
Європейська комісія
um Штати uh на веб-сайті uh
портал фінансування та тендерних можливостей
перелік національних контактних пунктів
ці національні пункти поведінки є
призначений вашим міністерством
і наскільки вони бачать Україну
ще не висунув їх, але вони є
Я думаю, що Вікторія буде номінована
все ще тут, Вікторія Гідо, тому вона
може прокоментувати це Вікторія, якщо
ти хочеш
Я не впевнений, чи вона мене чує
так, я чую, добре, можливо, ти б це зробив
подобається коментувати Вікторія, так, звичайно
про процеси призначення NCP ми
насправді є посередині, так, ми маємо
зробили деякі
гм, деякі люблять зміни в інструкції в нашій
NCP Network, яку ми плануємо номінувати
вони принаймні, щоб надати список
для наших європейських партнерів
кінець липня перед другим ух
етап переговорного процесу про
наша участь у Горизонті
Європи та про відсутність
інформації
про The Horizon Europe, ну, я також
хочу сказати, що ти насправді
можна також перевірити інформацію на нашому
Національний портал «Горизонт 2020» досі
доступний, і він все ще опублікований
трохи інформації про вебінари та
семінари про наступну програму
насправді йдеться про Horizon Europe, але
так, звичайно. Наш намір полягає в тому, щоб
перед початком і запуском
Horizon Europe тут, в Україні
надати більше інформації та інше
навчання та семінари, як практич
вебінари для наших зацікавлених сторін
будь ласка, якщо ви хочете, ви також можете
зв'яжіться зі мною, у нас є список
зацікавлені сторони, які вже є
зацікавлені, і вони застосовують його через наш
анкету, яку ми фактично надсилаємо
це під час
грудень 2020 року, а також лютий 2021 року
тому ми також надіслали їм
гм, як короткі розклади на один місяць або
на два тижні вперед про все
актуальні події про Horizon Europe
так, добре, дякую, вибачте, можливо
задайте ще одне запитання, як я вже сказав
написання пропозицій, ми повинні почати
від 20, тому хочу лише купити
Буде відібрано 20 учасників
прокоментуйте критерії
Дякую
Фелікс, ти хочеш
мікрофон
Я можу прокоментувати це, тому що минулого разу
Я був тим, хто вибирав, коли
організації в Україні, тому є декілька
технічні заходи, які є
необхідним є технічний
Домовленість за умови належного знання англійської мови
знання англійської друга була є
там уже визначена тема
як або кілька, які схожі на огляд
беручи участь чи в пре
um кроки розвитку
на певний дзвінок
як і попередні програми
як налагодити контакти з uh
потенційні партнери по співпраці за кордоном
певні потреби, які стосуються
в
участь Я думаю, що це було б так
головні критерії так
звісно, ​​існує також гендерний баланс
якщо можливо і є як не мати
з одного закладу більше одного
людина добре, якщо це багато, якщо це a
Велика організація, можна також сказати
раніше я маю на увазі останній раз на тренуванні
в Україні в 2019 році була певна закономірність
ін-ту зварювання кількох учасн
тому що я маю на увазі, що це було так само, як там
було так багато заявок
це те, що ви не могли ввійти туди
різні відділи величезні
організація так так
це критерії
є дві особи, які є
тренери, які оцінюють, а потім це також
як е-е прокоментував з міністерством якщо
є певна особливість ми
слід відобразити більше в списку
учасників
Велике спасибі, Фелікс, я опублікував над
чат посилання на Український вік 2020
портал
про це Вікторія говорила
тож я думаю, ти зможеш знайти
інформація там і контакт
У мене так, у мене є одна проблема
не стосується організації
маю досвід роботи з додатками
Я маю на увазі, що це дуже гарне запитання
і часто це вирішальне
питання, чи хочете ви приєднатися чи ні
Ваші дослідницькі завдання щодо вищої освіти
ніби трохи незрозуміло всередині, і я маю на увазі я я
сказав би подивіться хто брав участь з
Україна, щоб побачити, що є
університети, які дійсно успішні
і дуже добре, я маю на увазі, що у вас є
статистична річ, але ви також можете дістатися до неї
сам бенефіціар, тому що якщо ви йдете
до так званої приладової панелі
ви побачите, якщо подивіться на if I
можете опублікувати посилання на осцилятор, щоб ви могли
знайти, хто був активним у Європі
активних в Україні можна поїхати на сам
хто є залученими організаціями
і тоді, якщо ви підете на певний
проекти, які вам подобаються, ідентифікують вас
можна дізнатися, хто там працював і
ну контакт ви можете знайти контакт
і ви можете обміняти як це, як uh
співпраця, можливо, це
університет на іншій стороні вул
вулиці, і ви можете, як поговорити з
особа вільно як зникла і як
як іде робота як це реалізовано I
означаю, можливо, одноранговий обмін
найплідніший і знаючи ваш
культура, з людьми дуже легко спілкуватися
люди також розкривають інформацію
це не те, що ви приховуєте інформацію, як
в інших країнах, тому що це ну, але
але це ніби є давай як
розуміння обміну досвідом
і, можливо, це найдорожче
інформацією, яку ви можете отримати
досвід з тими, хто був таким
успішно, тому я опублікую вам
цей інструмент, де ви можете знайти все
профінансував проекти, і тоді ви також можете
дізнатись хто такі українці я буду
спробуй, ой, видобути, це нелегко, я
хотів поділитися з вами оцінкою
підсумковий звіт до речі е-е Життєвість якщо
ви дозволите мені, я можу зробити, дозвольте мені просто
перебити вас просто на короткий час
зауваження з мого боку, ну, я говорив
про код цієї бази даних і це
що я робив, поки ти говорив
Фелікс, я саме збирався це записати
бази даних, і я витягнув усе
Українські учасники 2020 року
в основному, якщо ви натиснете це посилання, ви
знайде всіх українських учасників у
вік 2020, а потім ви можете вибрати далі
їх так ліворуч, що ви можете побачити для
приклади різних фільтрів, таких як поле
галузь застосування науки і так далі
і так далі і в основному фінансування
схема, і тоді ви можете побачити, хто такий
хто вже брав участь у
вік 2020 з України і тоді можна
справді зв’яжіться з цими колегами
наступне зауваження стосується е-е-е-е
знову інформація, яку я вже опублікував
посилання на інформаційні дні Horizon Europe
У 2021 році вони зрештою відбудуться
ну червень початок липня і все
сеанси будуть записані, щоб ви могли
подивіться їх потім, і це в моєму
переглянути принаймні чудову відправну точку так
якщо у вас немає досвіду в
розробка заявок на Horizon 2020
наприклад, це те, з чого я б почав
Подивіться на ці інформаційні сесії та спробуйте
щоб зв'язатися з колегами в
Україна, але також і в Європі, і це
ось як я особисто вчинив би
цей випадок
дякую, Фелікс тепер повернувся до вас
ми повинні зробити перерву
принаймні 20. це залежить це залежить
на наших учасників курсу 15 хв
принаймні так, я маю на увазі, що вам потрібно зламати
бо ти колись будеш спікером
більше
і я ціную це, так
тому, можливо, добре мати 15
хвилинна перерва, а потім почати
вчасно
як за порядком денним плюс п'ять
хвилин також добре, але
Гаразд, я думаю, ми зможемо, ми можемо почати, е-е, просто
відповідно до
друге замовлення - це добре, так це точно
за графіком наступний старт
так, віртуальна перерва була коротшою
це добре, тому що ми не можемо говорити з кожним
інший
ми йдемо далі добре
правильно, я пишу це в чаті для
кожен
український час
13 45.
побачимось
іноземні
Тож шановні колеги за чверть до другої
Україна, тому пора рухатися далі
і наша наступна презентація
займається какурі Maurice GLaDOS
дії msca
і дозвольте мені спочатку дати вам деякі загальні відомості
враження
перш за все, якщо ви пам'ятаєте
структура горизонту Європа, яку ви бачите
Реакції Маріскоса розташовані всередині
стовп чудової науки поруч
Європейська дослідницька рада та
дослідницької інфраструктури та в
жаргон Європейської комісії
відмінна наука означає високо
Інноваційний і виходить за рамки поточного
сучасний стан ось що є
очікується від ваших дослідницьких пропозицій якщо
ви будете фінансуватися з цього
в рамках цього стовпа, тому я сподіваюся
ми можемо продовжувати, я вимкну свою веб-камеру
знову
і рухатися далі
у нас є п'ять різних типів
Марістадовська кар'єра дії в межах в
другий стовп, з яким ми мали справу
спільні проекти в цьому стовпі
один Чудеса реакції ми маємо
наші спільні проекти
інституційні дії це
докторські мережі це співробітники
обміни та ну
у нас також є індивідуальні дії
здебільшого про постдокторські стипендії
тому ви можете подати заявку як один науковець
на постдокторську стипендію ім
nsca наприклад і у нас теж є
співфінансування обласних Національних і
міжнародні програми співфінансують це
ну
або випадок, коли у вас є нац
орган фінансування та цей орган фінансування застосовуються
для співзасновництва Європейським
комісії так цей Національний оригінал
орган фінансування повинен забезпечити нормально
докторські або стипендійні програми та
останнє, але не менш важливе, ми також маємо але ми
мають також дію під назвою MSA і
громадян
це про проведення по-європейськи
вечір дослідників для сприяння дослідженням
кар'єри
давайте подивимось на основні
принципи msca
і я сказав, що MSC розташовані в
pillar відмінна наука ось чому
наукова досконалість - це ну
один із найважливіших чи ймовірно
найважливіший критерій для цих
дії
це також стосується розвитку кар'єри
інноваційна наукова підготовка
і на відміну від uh всередині стовпа 2
MSC дотримуються так званого «знизу вверх».
підхід, який означає, що ви самі
вирішіть, про що ваші проекти
Немає жодних
положення від комісії ви
самі вирішуєте, ви самі придумаєте
із пропозицією дослідження, а потім вашим
ровесники
um розглянути ці пропозиції та оцінити
і знову ж таки окрім наукового
Досконалість мобільність в іншому
ключовий елемент кар'єри Marisko Doska
дії та говорити про мобільність ми
це транснаціональна мобільність
означає мобільність між країнами
це тому, що європеєць
Комісар вважає, що мобільність є
актив для кар'єри дослідника так
ви зможете навчитися іншого
дослідницький коледж, можливо, з іншого
мова і так далі і так далі ти є
очікується, що ви виїдете з вашого комфорту
зони і зіткнутися з
інша реальність в основному і є
ще один вид мобільності - мобільність
між академічним і неакадемічним
я про це говорив
раніше це стосується кар'єри
перспективи для
постдоки, які не можуть залишитися в
академічному секторі, і вони зобов’язані
мати навички справлятися з реальністю
в неакадемічному секторі в
промисловість також
робоча програма для MSA
2021-2022 щойно опубліковано
ця дата 15 червня 2021 року і знову я
надали тут гіперпосилання на це
робочу програму, де можна знайти все
опис майбутніх дзвінків це
схоже на те, про що я говорив
стовп теж ваша робота - читати
уважно ознайомтеся з цією документацією
зрозуміти масштаб і очікуване
результат цього конкретного дзвінка вам
зацікавлені подати заявку
давайте почнемо з огляду на
докторських мереж кін
тому докторська
мереж знову це інституція
спільний проект і знову
гм, це те саме правило 3 з трьох
в основному установи з країн-членів ЄС
держави та асоційовані країни утворюють і
мережа з дослідницькою програмою навчання
в тому числі індивідуальні проекти для
докторантів і подати заявку
фінансування, щоб ви створили консорціум
знову генерал
умова мінімальна умова — три вихідні
з трьох, але в основному комісія
каже приблизно шість-десять чи дванадцять
для членів є звичайною практикою
такий Консорціум і мета цього
Консорціум - це інноваційний тренінг
докторантів і кожен із них
кандидати мають максимум
36 місяців фінансування
кожного бенефіціара
um, як очікується, набере доктора
кандидат принаймні один доктор
кандидат із типовим місцем роботи
контракту та тих докторантів
може бути будь-якої національності та важливою
що принаймні це так
приклад у Німеччині, який ви можете надати
надати стипендію, для чого це важливо
мають трудовий договір на постійній основі
Трудовий договір в тому числі соц
Охоронне покриття
і гм
Важливо також те, що ті структурні
кандидати є
ще не отримали докторський ступінь
ступеня на момент часу
наймання бенефіціаром
знову принаймні три незалежні юридичні
юридичних осіб, кожна з яких створена в різних
Країна-член ЄС або Horizon Europe
Асоційована країна утворює Консорціум
і тоді одна з цих сутностей має бути
заснована в новій державі-члені
um, усі бенефіціари повинні
залучити принаймні одного докторанта
і ті докторські кандидати можуть бути
будь-якої національності
хм, є три різні типи
такі докторські мережі, такі докторські
самі мережі це класика
схемою її раніше називали європейською
навчальна мережа в Horizon 2020
знову ж таки, ви можете бути профінансовані як мінімум
360 людино-місяців це означає 10
докторантів протягом 36 місяців кожен
є схема, яка називається індустріальною
докторе про що це
гм
залучення промисловості в
навчання докторантів і
очікуються ті докторські кандидати
витратити принаймні 50 відсотків своїх
часу з галузевими партнерами
і у нас також вони називаються спільними
докторе, це про ну
спільна подвійна або багаторазова докторська
наукових ступенів і організацій, на які потрібно мати право
присудження докторських ступенів і не менше двох
інституцій має бути створено
в державі-члені або асоційованій
країна
Я говорив про те, що MSA є a
спеціальна програма мобільності в рамках
pillar відмінна наука ось чому
йдеться про правило мобільності
мережі докторантів, а також докторантів
не повинен проживати або здійснюватися
їхня основна діяльність у країні
бенефіціар найму на більш ніж
12 місяців і три за три роки
безпосередньо перед датою прийому на роботу
важливо дотримуватися цього
Правило мобільності
Дивлюсь на чат
гм
Думаю, я розгорну ваше запитання
Юрій потім, коли я буду говорити
про постдокторські стипендії
їдемо далі
спочатку давайте подивимося на фінансування
насамперед у докторських мережах
на відміну від спільних проектів у
стовп 2 тут знаходиться в докторантурі
мережах ми маємо справу з т. зв
фінансування витрат
це означає, що Європейська комісія
забезпечує цей союз одиничними витратами і там
немає е-е
бюджет тобі ти е-е
створіть себе і ви є
відшкодовується згодом
в першу чергу поділяються ці одиничні витрати
у витрати на одиницю дослідника та
вартість інституційної одиниці та дослідження
вартість одиниці складається з прожиткового мінімуму
Допомога на мобільність та сімейна допомога
і гм
прожитковий мінімум помножується на
поправочний коефіцієнт хостом
країни перебування та для України це
є новим для Horizon Europe 68 4,5 відсотка
і
гм
ви маєте право на отримання сімейної допомоги
якщо ви офіційно одружені або маєте
діти на утриманні і тепер ця сім'я
допомога може бути адаптована, якщо ви
отримати сімейні зобов'язання як a
дослідник під час дії
існує також так званий довгостроковий
відпустка це для випадку
коли ви відсутні більше 30
послідовних днів
гм, я не збираюся розширювати це
далі важливо для вас
зрозуміти, що поєднання
життя
мобільність і сімейна допомога якщо
застосовно, це ваш роботодавець
сума брутто тому все необхідне
внески на соціальне страхування
для нас податок буде вираховано
з цієї суми
а з іншого боку маємо
витрати інституційної одиниці складаються з
витрати на наукову підготовку та створення мережі
і управлінська та непряма
внески, тому опорні дослідження
витрати на навчання та мережу
ці витрати призначені для проведення цього
конкретний проект, тому в основному
Докторські кандидати мають принести користь
проекти повинні виграти від цих витрат
і управлінська та непряма
внески надходять до установи, яка
є бенефіціаром цього проекту
знову ж таки важливо, щоб ви подали заявку як
Консорціум, я знову сказав, ну, три вийшли
три це мінімальна вимога
але як докторант ви можете знайти
усі ці вакансії на
ваш портал доступу, і я надав a
гіперпосилання або посилання тут, і ви це побачите
головне меню робота та вакансії та фінансування
це де ви можете їх знайти
вакансії, які ви натискаєте на роботу та пошук
ви можете вибрати Horizon uh 2020 або
Horizon Europe ви можете вибрати msca та
тоді ви знайдете всі вакансії
там і ви як дослідник як доктор філософії
кандидат може претендувати на
ця конкретна схема фінансування
над порталом
тому процедура подання заявки на
Консорціум знову типовий підхід для
Європейське фінансування є єдиним запитом
заявки на рік
в робочій програмі ви знайдете
дати, коли відкривається дзвінок і коли він
знову закривається, я надав a
гіперпосилання на майбутній виклик
2021 для докторських мереж, і ви побачите
на якому насправді планувалося його відкрити
22 червня, але я думаю, що це ще не все
відкрито з технічних причин, але це
правильне посилання це правильне
гіперпосилання на цей виклик, і ви знову можете
дістаньтеся до порталу до знахідки
портал можливостей претендентів і
завантаження довідкових документів
уважно прочитайте їх і спробуйте зустрітися
очікування комісії
ви можете подати заявку на цю вісімку
наукових панелей вони всі заявлені
тут я не збираюся
читайте їх вголос, але в основному робіть
самі вирішуйте, яка вам панель
ви звертаєтеся з
знову критерії оцінювання схожі
як для всього проекту Horizon a Euro this
є і є також невизначений Фактор так
Досконалість способів для 50 вплив на 30 і
реалізація для 20
і є новий регламент для
Пропозиція Horizon Europe подана в
попередній дзвінок
гм, і не набрав менше 80
відсотків не слід повторно подавати
наступного року, тож це означає, що це лише
застосовно до Horizon Europe, тому це означає
якщо ви подасте пропозицію в конкурсі 2021 року
і набрали менше 80 відсотків
не слід повторно надсилати в
2022 ви бачите, що формулювання досить
soft не слід повторно надсилати це не a
чітке твердження комісії
використовувати цей м’який підхід, але ми
очікувати, що починати буде важче
від холодного 2023 року так що вас не буде
дозволено повторно подати, якщо ви набрали очок
менше 80 відсотків
Дивлюсь на чат
Сподіваюся, поки що все зрозуміло
гаразд, давайте подивимося на співзасновництво
регіональні Національні та міжнар
програм співзасн
як я вже сказав, мова йде про
співзасновництво існуючого Нац
програм і є дві різні
лінії фінансування докторської програми
лінія для докторантів і
Лінія програми стипендій для постдокторів та
тут також є пропозиції щодо проектів
подаються приймаючими організаціями
отримані вакансії та вакансії
опубліковано опубліковано на euroxis
портал і дослідники звертаються безпосередньо до
вибрані організації
гм
ви як установчий орган як національна
орган фінансування, який ви отримаєте
хм, свого роду допомога на співфінансування
гм
ця надбавка повинна бути витрачена на
зарплата дослідника, і ви бачите
номери, вказані тут і
гм
[Музика]
це в основному, як це працює, ви так
ви повинні надати собі a
свого роду базове фінансування для
дослідником і співзасновником буде
надав єврокомісар
і знову це слайд, де ви можете
подивіться, ой, як це фільтрувати
тож ви в основному переходите до основного
меню та фінансування європейських досліджень
програму, то ви можете вибрати, наприклад
вік 2020 рік
nsca, і тоді ви можете знайти всі ці ну
вакансії на порталі та вас як PhD
кандидат або постдоктор, ви можете подати заявку
безпосередньо до установи, яка має
що видав цю вакансію на ваш
портал доступу
ми також заохочуємо окремих дослідників
щоб перейти до вашого порталу доступу та um
створити, щоб зареєструватися там і створити a
профіль на цьому порталі та завантажити
ваше резюме це збільшить ваше
видимість для потенційних роботодавців
приклад, і ви отримаєте автоматично
відповідне фінансування та пропозиції хостингу для
приклад
це приємна функція порталу
тепер перейдемо до докторантури MSA
стипендії
зараз мова йде про індивідуальне фінансування
вам не потрібен будь-який консорціум, який ви можете
застосувати
або фінансування постдокторської стипендії
як окремий дослідник
Гаразд, бюджет знизу вгору, я думаю, це так
ясно
хм, у нас закінчується час, ось чому
Я намагаюся бути трохи швидшим, тому
нове положення тут ви повинні
бути постдоктом у кінцевий термін
очікується 12 жовтня цього року
рік і у вас такий європейський
комісія запровадила наук. вік
тому ви маєте право подати до восьми
років після PhD
перерви в кар'єрі не враховуватимуться
обліковий запис і знову ваша установа
ваша приймаюча установа зобов’язана
provide your uh надати вам a
трудовий договір повний робочий день в т.ч
Соціальне забезпечення, як я вже сказав, у Німеччині для
наприклад, стипендії MSC не є такими
можливо
і ви подаєте заявку як дослідник з
приймаюча установа, яка повинна бути активною
в дослідженнях і розробках так
університет
Науково-дослідна установа SME, що діє в
дослідження і так далі і так далі
у нас є два напрямки програми
хм, у постдокторських стипендіях ми маємо a
Європейська програма стипендій і ми
мати глобальну програму стипендій
і
гм
також є актив для обох програм
рядків, тому в кінці вашого проекту ви
може провести до шести місяців
неакадемічний сектор
так
гм
дозволь мені
знову це ці вісім панелей
чому я не збираюся розширювати це
більше, але давайте подивимось на
Європейська програма європейська стипендія
рядок програми, щоб ви витратили від одного до двох
рік
хм, два роки дослідження в
Європа, і у вас є цей варіант
відрядження в неакадемічний сектор вгору
до шести місяців, можливо, постдок
будь-якої національності, але від вас вимагається
дотримуватися цього правила мобільності, тому в
останні три роки менше 12 місяців при
кінцевий термін дзвінка, в якому ви повинні були проживати
у цій конкретній країні знову ваш
приймаюча установа повинна бути
активно займається дослідженнями та розробками
вісім наукових панелей Це зрозуміло
і Global Fellowship це хм про е-е
повернення знань до Європи, тому ви
провести від одного до двох років дослідницького перебування
і за межами Європи, наприклад в
третя країна, як-от США, Канада, Австралія
і так далі ну і лише правило мобільності
застосовується до цієї третьої країни, а не до
країни до приймаючої країни в Європі
а потім маєте обов'язкове повернення
етап одного року в Європу і це
заохочення до роботи шість місяців
хм, неакадемічний сектор знову буде
мають право подати заявку на цей напрям програми
ви повинні мати громадянство члена
державою або асоційованою країною або бути
так звані довгострокові резиденти, тому ви
мав прожити в Європі принаймні
п’ять років поспіль, а у вас два
приймаючі установи u один господар
установа в Третій країні це
буде вашою партнерською організацією та
один у державі-члені або асоційованій
країни для фази повернення та це
установа в членстві Асоцій
країна буде вашим роботодавцем для
весь час вашого спілкування
подібний підхід з um
знову відповідаємо, у нас є дослідницький підрозділ
витрати, і ми маємо інституційну одиницю
витрати
і знову жива мобільність і сім'я
надбавка на складають ваш
валова сума роботодавця і
um всі обов'язкові внески на
Соціальне забезпечення та оподаткування будуть
вираховується з цієї суми
тому чиста сума буде
трохи нижче
тому ви запитували про цей доступ
ставки це показники успіху в
У 2020 році це була докторська стипендія
раніше називалися індивідуальними товариствами
тому якщо назвати 2020 рік
у нас були підпанелі
стандартні європейські стипендії
більше не буде підпанелей, крім вас
можна побачити європейські стипендії
ця швидкість доступу становить приблизно 12-15
відсотків і це трохи вище для
Глобальні стипендії, тобто близько 20-23
відсотків
це загальний показник успіху для
Європа
як аналогічний підхід для програми
процедура, яку я надав тут гіперпосилання
до MSA
Конкурс на стипендію на постдокторську ступінь у 2021 році
ви йдете на пошук і тендер
портал можливостей, з якого ви завантажуєте
шаблони, для яких ви завантажили посібник
заявників, і ви намагаєтеся звернутися до кожного
єдиний бал, який очікується Комісією
у цьому дзвінку
гм, ви можете подати заявку до
це буде дата закриття
12 жовтня 2021 року це завжди 17:00
Брюссельський місцевий час
гм
і знову ми маємо цю нову постанову
з повторною подачею, тому якщо ви набрали очок
70 відсотків або менше ви будете
не рекомендується повторно подавати та
гм
це в основному
найважливіше, що вам знати
можливо часові рамки такі європейські
у комісії є ще п'ять місяців
оцініть свою пропозицію, щоб отримати
ваші результати до кінця березня або
до середини березня 2022 року або
найпізніше тоді у вас буде три місяці
для підготовки шліфувальної землі тощо
приблизно в червні 2022 року ви будете
необхідно підписати ваш Грант
угоду, і тоді ви можете почати свій
проект наступного місяця
підписання грантової угоди або при
принаймні через 12 місяців після підписання гранту
Угода
тож давайте подивимося на персонал
біржі цього типу дій
особливо популярний у Associated
вставте країни
а це приблизно
гм
Міжнародний та міжгалузевий
співпраця та передача знань від
дослідження ринку і навпаки
це спільні дослідження та інновації
культура, але правило три з трьох
також застосовується тут
гм, двоє з цих членів мають бути з a
держава-член західної країни та один
особа може бути з третьої країни
приклад
і якщо всі установи з
один і той же сектор повинен бути з третього
країна, ось чому ця програма така
популярний у деяких країнах
тому в основному ви здійснюєте відрядження для
наші дослідники і
хм, вони можуть бути постдоками, вони можуть бути докторами філософії
кандидати, але вони також можуть бути
адміністративно-управлінський або технічний
персонал, який підтримує діяльність rni, і вони
мають обов’язкову фазу повернення
відрядні установи
гм
мова йде про створення взаємодоповнювальних
компетенції в участі
організація це стосується кар'єри
Розвиток — це мережеве спілкування та
такий проект можна профінансувати для чотирьох
років і кожна людина може
тому кожен проект може бути профінансований
um фінансується протягом 360 профі та місяців
тому ми знову маємо справу з одиничними витратами
тільки тут і комісія надає
так звану додаткову допомогу для
відряджених співробітників і цього Доповнення
Допомога покриває проживання в дорозі
і пов'язані з цим витрати на проживання
економіки та закладу отримують
гм
витрати на наукову підготовку та створення мережі
і управлінські та непрямі
внески
це знову посилання на майбутнє
Виклик 2021 ви бачите дату тут
на слайді
і
гм
це
слайд про європейські дослідження
керівник NGC ріамп і Рія є
установчий орган для досліджень і
Інновація, вона керує вашими дослідженнями
гранти, тому Європейська комісія є a
політична інституція, а Ріа є
орган фінансування і Рія має свій власний
веб-сайт і на цьому веб-сайті ви також можете
знайти інформацію про Америку
реакції та як застосувати це дуже
це описано в дуже точному і
ясний спосіб, на мій погляд
так що тепер я досяг точки, де я
потрібна вода і я
хотів би відповісти на ваші запитання
як я вже, наскільки я можу бачити, закінчилося
чат
Немає жодних
запитання без відповіді, відео
підтвердити
так, я маю на увазі, було питання що
призначений для його кар'єри, що є насправді
хороше запитання, і якщо це подобається
відноситься до
перспектива кар'єри, як розуміння
і заклад так це добре
питання, але розуміння на uh
з боку програми трохи
інакше, я намагаюся пояснити це, можливо, ви
може навіть краще пояснити, що це таке
мається на увазі кар'єра так
впевнений, тому що особливо для тих
індивідуальні досягнення
вважається, що це дещо відрізняється від
як гм е-е відкладення так
так, дякую, FedEx, ні, це не так
звичайно лише про віковий індекс
тому що я намагався це пояснити
приблизно
гм, ширший погляд, наприклад, якщо ви є
кандидат наук
очікується, що ти зможеш бути
працевлаштування в академічній та в
неакадемічний сектор
оскільки
ми всі знаємо, що лише меншість усіх
а постдоки можуть залишатися в
академічному секторі або готові залишитися
в академічному секторі, можливо, і це
важливо, що вони є
гм, тоді вони мають Знання та
Навички для досягнення успіху в Академії
а також у неакадемічних колах
це про кар'єру це те саме
для постдокторської стипендії, в основному
якщо ви подаєте заявку на постдокторантку
стипендії, які вам знадобляться
опишіть, як це сприяє вашому
розвиток кар'єри батька, тому що так
який твій наступний крок в основному
і гм
знову комісія витрачає ці гроші на
постдокторські стипендії, щоб
надати вам знання та навички
що дозволить вам бути дуже успішним
дослідник
um незалежно від того, чи в none в
академічний чи неакадемічний сектор
Сподіваюся, це зрозуміло
хм так, і хтось скаже мені, що робить горизонт
отримав бакалаврську або магістерську програми
гм
ні, це не про бакалавра чи магістра
програми
гм
але я маю на увазі, що б це
підтримує Італію, якщо ви виправите мене
якщо я не правий, тому що я не експерт
на цьому, але є такі речі
обміни, і вони дійсно ух
правильно, він може інтегрувати не лише PO
лікар або або вони також включають
кандидати і так далі, я маю на увазі
зазвичай зазвичай FedEx вам потрібен
Ви повинні бути доктором філософії
або постдок або управлінський персонал
um пов'язаний з дослідженнями так дослідження
діяльність є ядром, тому це не так
про отримання ступеня бакалавра
приклад, це дослідження
діяльності
ну, в принципі, ви повинні бути принаймні a
Кандидат на докторську дисертацію має право на отримання
брати участь в обміні кадрами для
приклад
Гаразд
Європейська комісія розглядає
фінансування центрів передового досвіду
гм
є ух
звичайно
гм
Ініціатива Європейського університету і там
є національними центрами передового досвіду, але
Я боюся, що ви говорите про
Національні центри передового досвіду Олександр
ось чому це питання
до українського міністерства я
боїться
гм
як щодо заявників на підтримку, які мають
більше 70, але не мають
я думаю про це питання
було достатньо відповіді ми маємо це
знак досконалості ініціативи
комісії та про що говорила Юлія
національні зусилля з пристосування до цього
ситуація так в основному, наскільки я
зрозуміти принаймні Україна збирається
розробити національну програму
забезпечити національне фінансування для тих, ну
пропозиції, які отримали вищі бали
звання, але не змогли отримати належне фінансування
до бюджетних обмежень, я думаю, Вікторія
міг би прокоментувати це
Я сподіваюся, що Вікторія ще з нами
так, я все ще тут, насправді, так, ти
безперечно праві, що ми плануємо
почати національну програму, як я думаю
наприкінці липня цих років ми приймали
перший насправді перший
ну
ну перші дзвінки по цій програмі є
буде відкрито, і ми сподіваємося
що фінансовий First Financial
внески та підтримка є
забезпечення до кінця цього року
грудень 2021 року, тож якщо я вам знадоблюсь
надати будь-яку додаткову інформацію
будь ласка, просто зв'яжіться зі мною, я просто поділюся цим
мої контакти електронної пошти в попередньому
повідомлення про центри передового досвіду
наскільки мені відомо, Вікторія, я дуже дякую
сподіваюся, відповідь була достатньою для вас
Олександр
Я розумію, що маю на увазі це це
ситуація з державним фінансуванням
ти краще за мене знаєш, що відбувається
і я не збираюся це коментувати, але
в основному ви бачите, що міністерство
намагається вирішити цю проблему
і тепер у мене інша проблема
тому що в мене залишилося менше 10 хвилин
для частини ERC, і я не я не
знаю, я хочу запитати вас скільки
Вас цікавить саме це?
частина чи є тут учасники, які
зацікавлені в
коли я почув про ERC, просто дозвольте мені
знати в чаті, будь ласка, тоді ми зможемо
вирішити спонтанно
Гаразд
це добре знати, тому що я ні
збиратись
говорити про речі, якими ти не є
цікавить добре чудово тоді рухаймося
на
давайте подивимося на основи ERC
Поперше
гм можливо
можливо, у нас зараз європейський футбол
Чемпіонат табору і, може, це добре
відправною точкою для мене ви знаєте, якщо ви
Подивіться на європейське фінансування, так що, Марі
Кюрі та ERC розташовані в межах
стовп відмінна наука і порівняння
це з футболом було б як е-е
Марія Кюрі - це Євроліга
а ERC – це Ліга чемпіонів
так в основному
знову звертаючись до вашої кар'єри
перспектива, яку я б написав, наприклад
моя пропозиція щодо наступного кроку
крок кар'єри після постдокторської
стипендія буде подати заявку на ERC
Грант, тому що це точно
наступний етап це на етапі де
ти утверджуєшся як незалежний
головний дослідник і ви створили
ваша власна дослідницька група, наприклад і
Ви бачите, що наукова досконалість є єдиною
Критерій ERC і ERC є завжди
про високий ризик High Gain це
ще одна відмінність від Марії Кюрі
очікується, що частини вашої пропозиції
бути високим ризиком, і це особливо
важливо для фундаментального
дослідження, тому що всі розуміють
якщо ви проведете фундаментальне дослідження
ви підете на високий ризик і, звичайно, ви це зробите
не завжди успішний, але є
важливо принаймні спробувати, тому що a
негативна відповідь також є відповіддю
важливо спробувати, я сподіваюся на це
ясно, і знову це знизу вгору
як Марія Кюрі, тож ти сам собою
вирішити, з якою пропозицією ви подаєте заявку
тож у нас є три різні цілі
групи у нас є стартові підстави у нас є
консолідатор підстав і маємо
авансові гранти
Ви можете прочитати визначення тут
себе, щоб заощадити час, я не збираюся
щоб прочитати вголос давайте продовжимо
є вікові обмеження
починається через два-сім років
PhD Консолідований приблизно від 7 до 12 років
після PhD Advanced grants немає
вікові обмеження тут
ви бачите тривалість і максимум
бюджет тут, давайте рухатися далі це
умова для проекту так ви
очікується витратити принаймні 50 50 40 30
відсотків
гм на вашому проекті ERC і 50 50 50 дюймів
ЄС або асоційована країна
гм, від вас вимагається витратити
знову це детальний опис
умова для початку Grant ви будете
отримайте цю презентацію згодом
Я не буду читати це вголос
те саме для консолідаторів Grants і
те саме для розширених грантів
і
хм, ти бачиш це
дзвінки у 2021 році, починаючи з і
консолідатор вони вже закриті
розширений грант відкритий, і ви все ще можете
подати заявку до 31 серпня
хм, це орієнтовний календар дзвінків
на 2022 рік програми роботи 2022 немає
офіційно прийнято ще тільки тому
орієнтовні дати
і ось як ти в основному
обчисліть свій період придатності для
2022 для запуску та скасування даних
гранти, які я надав тут
Докторську нагороду, і якщо ви встигнете до цієї дати
ви матимете право подати заявку
різні правила для мед
лікарі, я не буду розширювати це
зараз, щоб заощадити час
і звичайно є такі
продовження, наприклад, декретної відпустки
батьківська відпустка військовий або срібний
Служба тривала хвороба так все
якщо ви не можете
проводити дослідження не візьмуться
в обліковому записі
тож тепер давайте трохи поговоримо про
на відміну від Марії Кюрі, де ми працюємо
з вартістю одиниці це знову типово
підхід, який ми знаємо зі стовпа 2 так
ти маєш
гм, ти можеш
um в основному буде відшкодовано для всіх
спрямувати прийнятні витрати до 100 і ці
прийнятними витратами можуть бути, наприклад, a
заробітна плата головного дослідника або
цілих проектних команд, як ви
напевно знадобиться як лідер групи
певні постдоки або аспіранти чи ні
визначення і так далі і так далі
курс витратні матеріали вартість обладнання та
за витрати на обладнання, якщо вам потрібно більше
машини, наприклад, ви купуєте або
іншу інфраструктуру, тому ви отримаєте
так звана норма амортизації означає, що
ця інфраструктура може бути використана після
проект був завершений, і все
чому вам буде відшкодовано лише вартість
для цього конкретного проекту
курс транспортні витрати витрати на публікацію
і підрядні та інші і як
завжди непрямі витрати, це квартира
ставка 25 відсотків прямих витрат
як уже згадувалося, є лише
один критерій оцінки наук
досконалість і знову про це
про новаторську природу
амбіції та видимість звичайно і
це знову про високий ризик
в основному ви повинні підійти
з новою науковою ідеєю так
гм
як скажімо
um пов'язаний з covet цей uh підхід
наприклад, з новими мРНК-вакцинами
які були розроблені, тому це нове
підхід це високий ризик я отримати і
це означає ERC
на відміну від Марії Кюрі є двоступінчастою
оцінка
гм перший етап
um тільки b1o пропозиція є
оцінили, а потім
гм
у вас буде другий етап
мати співбесіду, на яку я не збираюся
розгорніть це, тому що ми працюємо
розклад
і гм
ви можете підійти в основному ми завжди
рекомендуємо звернутися до свого національного
контактний пункт або буде призначено
міністерство як ми зрозуміли і
звичайно, ви можете підійти до порталу
для пошуку та тендерних можливостей
тому що інформації багато
також зазначено там
ой, я бачу питання
гм
ERC для окремих дослідників це
є саме точкою ERC ERC ви
претендувати на роль головного дослідника
навіть у вашій приймаючій установі ви можете
просто перемістіть приймаючий заклад
це ваш індивідуальний проект і якщо
ви не задоволені своїм постом
установа, яку ви можете змінити
ваш приймаючий заклад і відвідати
ще один, але звичайно це так
важливі з точки зору ресурсів, які
ваша приймаюча установа може надати
ви з необхідним обладнанням для
приклад для проведення вашої пропозиції
так
Я знову запускаю камеру, я не бачу
будь-яке подальше запитання надходить до
чат
гм
Я думаю
або все зрозуміло або нічого
ясно
це два варіанти
гм, але в будь-якому випадку ви можете зв’язатися
Розповісти нам після цієї сесії та, звичайно
якщо є якісь запитання, посилаючись
до MSC або Arc я зможу я буду
радий відповісти на них
Фелікс гм
віддаю тобі так, дуже дякую
я маю на увазі, що є як у вас
пощастило, що Вітале з нами, бо
він теж над цим інтенсивно працює
він знає всі питання msca і ESC
гранти
хм, це дійсно добре, але загалом
ми також намагаємося в таборах не зосереджуватися на
особистість
стипендій, тому ми зосередимося на цьому
представлені кластери кластерів або
мережевих підходів, які також є в
Одяг Марії або в тому, що я
коротко викладу, отже
це також як точка зору для нас
щодо цієї можливості навчання
хм, ти не можеш згадати Інтернет
адреси, звичайно, ні, але ви будете
отримати презентації та
доступ до нього в наступні дні е-е, я не маю
знаєте, як ми це організували минулого
тренінгів, які ми наче розповсюдили
і все спрацювало досить добре, можливо, я
треба просто рухатися до останнього
у нас є презентація, яка постачається разом із
EIC, а також горизонтальні питання
можливо це добре почати
якщо у вас немає дуже термінових питань
але зазвичай термінові питання
приходьте після всієї презентації так
зверніть увагу також на питання, якщо у вас є
або після цієї короткої презентації або
можливо, може, не надто коротко, але принаймні
для Pathfinder він трохи менший a
трохи коротша інформація ніж або
горизонтальні проблеми, я вже можу орієнтуватися
крізь нього, тому, коли ви подивіться знову
це загальна структура, де ми
зараз, тому ми права рука в
Рада інновацій і як назва
вже говорить, що це спрямовано головним чином на
Інновації компаніям і тим, хто
співпрацювати з ними
так гм
тож є як би високі бюджетні кошти
для серії, а у вас фактично три
поля та інструменти, які є
підтримується тут, я вас познайомлю
але питання в тому, як їм подобатися
звернутись до нього найкраще, тому що є деякі
частини, які вже були
які вийшли за межі терміну і є
вже закрито, тому що Інновація
Рада не чекала рішення
Horizon Europe та офіційний запуск
це почалося вже раніше його
особливо в Pathfinder
Так, у більшості випадків все йде знизу вгору
він скоріше верхній або максимально відкритий
теми насправді
їдемо далі
тож ви бачите тут дві проблеми, тоді як
перший уже закритий, але у вас є
друге виклики EIC Pathfinder
який виглядає на виклик
керований курс для конкретних технологій
однак це вже
ЗАЧИНЕНО
і насправді у вас є п'ять зверху вниз
проблеми, які ви знайдете тут
обізнаність Інсайдер завжди a
опис цієї тканини мозку
генна терапія
виробництво водню живе
матеріалів
це п'ять завдань зверху вниз
а що шукають, то нового
технології
тому науково обґрунтовані технології є
шукав тут і ви насправді маєте
відкритий отвір, який закривається в жовтні
тому ідея є доказом принципу
та підтвердження наукового та
про технологічні етапи мова не йде
створення виробничих потужностей але
це про розбиті перегони щодо
комерціалізація, але це не те
процес комерціалізації це три
кроки до цього
хм так зазвичай це виглядає занадто високо
технічні підприємства
але це також може бути
як дослідники на початку кар'єри
залучені до таких процесів у вас є
багато інформації про це і багато іншого
також більше цільової інформації та
Я хотів би також нагадати вам про
Інформаційні дні ЄС, щоб ви інформували
з понеділка ви можете подивитися, що є
розклад у вас там конкретний
пояснення близько двох годин
кожне з питань, які ми представляємо сьогодні так
дійсно має сенс подивитися, що є
найпривабливіший
проблеми тут для вас, а потім ви можете
як стрибок у ці спеціальні дні введення
оскільки ми можемо дати вам лише огляд
через півгодини так звичайно так і зараз
ми переходимо до розподілу участі
проблема у вас є
гм насправді кілька напрямків
так звані напрямки, які шукають у ньому
так що у вас є ось де ми зараз так
це горизонталь
um тематичний підхід знизу вгору
у вас тут це виглядає з двох питань
дивідендна участь і спред
Досконалість з одного боку, але ви побачите
коротше кажучи, що означає відмінність
а потім є як реформування і
посилення досліджень та інновацій
Система, яка має ну як деякі загальні
цілі, звичайно, це
звичайно є бюджетування
у вас не так багато бюджету, як у
інші, але це важливо
це цей аксесуар призначення
напрямки ставили тому що їм подобається
покладаються на цілі або пов’язані з ними
ця мета і ось у вас є
насправді одна робоча програма, яка стосується
усі, крім цільових пунктів підтримки
як ви бачили справедливість, яка є
у вас є мультикастери
призначення, що означає цілі
представлені
однак, якщо ви помістите їх, як у a
список, щоб побачити, яке фінансування ви бачите
тут ліворуч, як коротко
доступні інструменти
деякі інструменти легко зрозуміти
з самого формулювання
тож якщо ви бачите тут слово об’єднання
побратимство
Ви можете собі уявити, що це таке
і деякі інші проблеми також
описав одну проблему, де ви
читайте тут Ініціативи досконалості це
має дещо інше поняття центрів
досконалість виглядає також у
Інноваційна екосистема і не виглядає
на Excellence всередині в наших випадках так
ви повинні бути дуже обережні, коли подібне
розуміння ідей з огляду але
є деякі, я маю на увазі, що це вам допоможе
зорієнтуватися
тож тепер ми йдемо в це
так є така ідея
збільшення інтенсивності наших очей і там
деякі зміни, які потрібно внести
тут і там інноваційний розрив і
якщо ви бачите червоні лінії, ви бачите це
це нові країни-члени, і я маю на увазі
з останніх хвиль входження і ти
є як кілька помаранчевих ставок жовтого
частин, тому є різниця в
ідеї також для подолання цієї інновації та
дослідницька прогалина, оскільки вони також є в a
спосіб
гм країни, які також реформуються
з добре відомих вам структур
тому що вони частково люблять дзеркало
структур, які ви знаєте у своїй країні
і ось у вас є ці проблеми
заявників та координаторів з метою
є краща взаємодія
відповідні координатори, які мають
обов'язковий для багатьох заходів з
ті країни, які схожі
симптоми або не так багато інвестицій
а потім у вас є і тут ви також знайдете
асоційовані у вас країни
прийнятні країни, які приєднуються до дії
і співпрацювати в деяких діях
так, так, добре, було збільшення
над програмами, а також є
авансовий євро пакет
що приходить з цим визнанням
додаткових партнерів, які ви побачите
остання точка, щоб ви могли
переходити до існуючих проектів
що дійсно добре, так це Hop on yes, якщо ви
побачити хороший проект координатора
Консорціум погоджується, що ви можете включитися як
додатковий партнер, я б теж не довіряв
багато в цій можливості, але у випадку
це дійсно цікаво, і ви маєте
як деякі
um цілі, які доповнюють один одного
тоді це може бути справді
варіант, тому ви повернетеся до
перший пункт дуже важливий для вас
так, і тоді є інша підтримка
заходи, які приходять із цим просуванням
пакет тому переходимо до першого
у нас є три пункти призначення
ви бачите тут
мм фактично виїзди тривали два роки
але ви повинні бути дуже обережними, тому що
якщо ви подивіться на такі бюджети, ви побачите тут
наприклад два етапи в Першому на
об'єднання двох етапів
але це не означає, що весь
процес uh виведення вперед a
проект і проект програми має
буде зроблено в 2022 році
але це може початися вже зараз
тому що може бути двоступеневим
процедури, які останнє визначення
довше добре і я піду швидко
через усі ці питання тут ви бачите
остання The Hope на об'єкті це
справді станеться у 2022 році, тому що лише тоді
у вас є запущені проекти від Horizon
Європа, і тоді ви можете стрибати на вас
зараз не можу сісти, тому що
бігу немає
[Музика]
проекти
добре, тому є об’єднання під назвою Це
є двоступеневим є випуск
створення центрів передового досвіду та
Ви бачите тут Консорціум, отже, у вас є
мати неефективну державу
науково-дослідна установа
а потім приходять партнери, які є
доповнюють і підтримують цю команду
ось вам подобається ідея мати
Ви бачите два крайні терміни, тому виклик є
відкрито, у вас є двоетапна процедура
це як крайній термін того року
другий термін настає лише для тих, хто
вибираються для просування вперед у
другий етап також
і ці проекти дійсно гарні
фінансується, тому дійсно має сенс перетинати
перевірити командні можливості, але бути
обережні заявники повинні бути з
ці країни, які були перелічені
раніше
у вас також є можливість
навчання, щоб просувати дослідження
установи через партнерські кораблі
тож у вас також має бути тут
заявника від цих нових членів
країни або держави, що мають низькі результати
але ти можеш стати партнером
тож у вас повинно бути хороше партнерство
з одним із цих жовто-помаранчевих
країн, то є шанс
співпрацювати, якщо у вас є, наприклад
ця Румунія хороше партнерство тоді там
була б можливість запитати, чи вони
ніби ви знаєте цю можливість навчання
і ви б хотіли
співпрацювати в цьому, але ви повинні бути
провідна науково-дослідна установа
гм
або ви це має бути загальним лідером
науково-дослідні установи, які співпрацюють у
що
і тут у вас є лише один крайній термін
проектів трохи менше
однак фінансується більше проектів
заходи коротші, так що так
напевно, їх нелегко ідентифікувати
які планують зробити побратимство
але, можливо, у вас ідеальний хороший контекст
що ти можеш заскочити туди
добре, і тоді у вас є ця відмінність
тому є додатки, яким вони не присвячені
центри передового досвіду в сенсі
дослідницькі центри передового досвіду це виглядає
про інноваційні екосистеми бізнесу
а й на ніші спеціалізації
економічні ніші, які можуть мати вигоду
від кращих інноваційних екосистем
і так, так, дві екосистеми повинні
партнер
і компанії повинні е-е
так, брати участь, і це насправді так
також розробити стратегію
з впливом у цій структурі
так і потім стати знову
тому обсяг повинен містити дослідження
проекти, а також інвестиційний план для
стратегія, яку потрібно принести
вперед
і так, є більше посилань
з економікою та просуванням
економічні ніші тут
ви бачите проект, який у вас є три
п'ять мільйонів проектів
також відносно
ну мало
але і ви повинні подзвонити у вас є
виклик відкривається в тому році, але крайній термін
далі тому, що такі Партнерства і
Регіональним партнерствам потрібно більше
підготовка також переконати
зацікавлені сторони, як правило, не залучені
такі схеми фінансування, оскільки також
гм
певні регіональні органи влади або
муніципалітети приєднаються
Європейська ініціатива досконалості
виглядає на
науково-технічний потенціал
закладів дивиться на потужність
будівництво та профіль Excellence
можливо, здається, що це більше спрямовано на
підключення вже існуючих відмінно
центрів, тому це також посилання на
центри передового досвіду, але є
немає необхідності мати офіційну печатку
Досконалість або будь-що, що приноситься
вперед сюди
тож знову ми закликаємо відкрити
дедлайн того року бачите це небагато
менший, але він також більше спрямований на
дослідження
а потім розпочинається під’їзд
наступного року, тож будуть проекти
фінансується Horizon Europe
зацікавлені зміни, приєднавшись до цих
кластерів представлено систематично
кластери, представлені Віталієм
захочуть ідентифікувати себе в їхніх дзвінках
певні проекти та партнерства
підтримують і коли вони починають свою роботу
у вас є можливість зайти, щоб приєднатися
так
хм так, але є також оцінка
критерії, які трохи відокремлені від
звичайні критерії, а це означає
новий партнер повинен бути обґрунтованим
але це також хороший шанс
перейти на пізнішому етапі, де ви бачите
дуже добре, що ви хочете спробувати тут
мати більшу кількість проектів і ви
також є два терміни
це означає, що конкурс розпочнеться наступного року
тоді у вас є двоетапна пропозиція
ну
процедура відбору
теж гарне призначення, ми все ще в межах
це написання участі
у вас є кілька відмінностей
проблеми у вас є стільці таланти
стипендії для циркуляції мозку та як
ви бачите, що вони всі всередині
22 давайте переїдемо туди, щоб у вас було
помилка стільців можна залучити вчених
і члени команди також можуть фінансуватися таким чином
координатор приходить з подивимось
недостатньо продуктивний стан, а потім помилка
акціонер приходить ззовні
однак потрібно дивитися, якщо
асоційовані країни насправді
гм право на борг це питання
для NCPE або для інформаційних днів
поставити
тут у нас є цей BBC, це не так
Британська телерадіомовна компанія
стипендії епохи циркуляції мозку для
молодих дослідників
які мають, як
інтереси до закладу до
робити міжсекторну мобільність
це означає, що у вас є можливість
перейти з державної організації в a в
приватний сектор
у вас також є ці постдокторські стипендії
умови, як ви знаєте, існують ставки
які необхідно застосовувати
і це насправді відповідає
індивідуальні стипендії
гм які схожі
частина тут у вас є цей поперечний сектор
Мобільність
для молодих
дослідження
стрибати
тому насправді хороший бюджет
чисел
і було б цікаво заглянути
що
і тут у вас інша проблема
ще не повністю з'ясовано, тому що у вас є
помилкові таланти
які повинні залучати таланти
дослідники експерти або дослідження
оператори інфраструктури
але
ми просимо, ми все ще чекаємо дослідження, яке
проводиться на замовлення організації по
інформацію, щоб побачити, скільки це
як відповідне рішення для uh
для викликів
добре, тому це з цією маркою
і Дзвінок приходить також трохи пізніше чого
тому добре стежити, але можливо
інформацію вони також тут можуть представити більше
висновки вже
добре
гм ефект від усіх цих відбілювань
проблема полягає в тому, що нова мобільність приходить
познайомився з новими мережами, новими областями досліджень, новими
ринки, але також дивляться на дослідження
заклад і це ух певний
країни, які це
країни з низькими показниками, а також
звертаючись до асоційованих країн
тож коли ми прийдемо до останнього пункту призначення
що схоже на горизонталь, до якої ми приходимо
реформування та зміцнення
вся система досліджень та інновацій ми
маю менший бюджет на цю частину, але я
це все ще 440 мільйонів євро
є кілька проблем із підтримкою
тож у вас є річний курс
попередньо визначені теми
деякі з них є так званими опорними і
координація та підтримка дій, які
об’єднати важливих акторів
можливо, також просять міністерства
просять внести внесок або агентство
сприяти та брати участь
але у вас також є інструмент
так звані дослідження та інновації
дії, де ви можете зв’язатися з дослідженнями
для верху вниз
передплачена тема
так добре
є багато тем і цих тем
такі як 80.
так
політика підтримує, що це як a
певна тема, яка оголошується
написано, який вид підтримки політики
потрібний є і або пропонується як
ну так, тож питання відкрито
наука використання всіх наших результатів
також деякі проблеми щодо вищого
інститутів вищих навчальних закладів
і так далі гендерна рівність по горизонталі
теми, які ми знаходимо тут
а на другому в наступному виклику в
наступного року ми знайдемо інші теми
тут
тому цікаво подивитися, чи є у вас
теми, які ви висвітлюєте, і можете зробити свій внесок
тому що це не індивідуально є
також, як ви бачите, є
координація та підтримка дійових досліджень
і інновації це означає, що є
бути спільними
з’являться проекти і, можливо, ваші
організація найкраще може зробити внесок
ви бачите теми
[Музика]
покласти так насправді ми майже ми є
майже в кінці
ух є такий ух генерал
можливість заглянути в усі
інформація, яка надходить разом із фінансуванням
і ми також маємо таку робочу програму
об’єднує всі ці три напрямки
Я представив
і, можливо, ми підійшли до кінця лайка
вид ванної кімнати з такою кількістю інформації
якщо ми втратили багато учасників на
зустріч протягом дня, але
це цілком нормально, тому я вмикаю
камеру, тому що я маю на увазі, що настав час
побачити один одного знову
і, можливо, ми також можемо я не знаю, я
думаю, що це було як востаннє, можливо, ми
можна ковзати далі
які ні ні ні ні не потрібні
так що я думаю немає питань Фелікс
так далеко
ну насправді це мій намір
було давайте
активні давайте будемо інтерактивними і давайте е-е
запитайте наших учасників, чи є вони
будь-які запитання, яких ще не було
відповів, тому це ваше
можливість запитати їх, я відповів
запитання ну запитання щодо
гм, ваш атом, отже, в основному, е-мм, Іран
паралельно, але, наприклад, для ртуті
ти пишеш їх присвячуєш я думаю це було
один мільйон євро для докторантури
стипендії у випадку
гм, вони проводять дослідження в цій галузі
твій атом
Сподіваюся, Юрій. Це було гм
конкретну відповідь для вас
Отже, що означає відкрита наука?
хороше запитання так, так, я маю на увазі це
відкрита наука насправді є практикою
науки ну це
що інші можуть співпрацювати та
внесок, тобто дані дослідження є
показано нотатки Open Lab та інші дослідження
доступні процеси
гм, повторне використання та перерозподіл
досліджень
um, а дані схожі на um
було полегшено з цим відкритим
дослідження, так і відкрита наука
наука означає також часто обмінюватися результатами
з громадськістю
це не обмежується самою наукою
колеги чи академія, так воно і йде
поза межами, і це є багато
інформація про це навіть є
статут якщо я пам'ятаю так навіть якщо ви підете
до Вікіпедії ви знайдете добре
інформація про те, що таке відкрита відкрита наука
це неймовірно важливо і велике
і це привернуло велику увагу відкритої науки
також висунула відкритість ЄС
наукова хмара
де саме може бути те, що я згадав
спільні, як бази даних ozuti тощо
але є багато інших платформ
тому я вважаю, що цього достатньо
відповісти на це, якщо я можу додати Фелікса
відкриту науку я маю на увазі як загальну
Таке враження, що Європа є
інвестувати гроші в науку, отже це
гроші платників податків, і це важливо для
подолати цю прірву між
ця Вежа науки і звичайна
платника податків важливо пояснити
ой звичайний платник податків чому так
важливо витратити стільки грошей
наука
яка користь і це ух
насправді я маю на увазі останнє
Тип дії Марії Кюрі це
вечір дослідників, це ваш шанс
пояснити науку платнику податків
але також для учнів і студентів
Молоде покоління, щоб збільшити їх
інтерес до науки, тому що Європа є
залежить від науки, якої у нас немає
природні ресурси
хм, ти не знаєш, що багато олії або або
вугілля чи щось інше, від чого ми залежимо
науки на нашому наук
підхід і е-е, так, будучи в
еліта в деяких наукових галузях і
тому важливо переконати
кожен окремий платник податків, яким є наука
важливе питання, і це знову це
є найвищою метою
комісія
так
але є також я маю на увазі я маю на увазі там
також є аспектами відкритого доступу
Я маю на увазі, що це теж проблема, але
це зовсім інша пара
взуття, до якого потрібно відкрити доступ
дослідницькі інфраструктури, наприклад
де є вартість, де є
витрати, але ви все ще можете
доступ, наприклад, якщо у вас є витрати
виділено в проект Horizon Europe
так, тоді ви можете використовувати це для доступу та
щоб охопити такий курс, але це це
інший, але він все ще відкритий, але
слово відкрито в ньому, але воно має інше
значення та контекст
open Open Access також стосується a
культура публікації, тому що ви знаєте
багато відомих журналів
е-е, вони вимагають ембарго і
звичайно, ти не можеш
хм, ти знаєш, щоб хм
нехай ваші однолітки знають, що ви
результати ваших досліджень і
ось чому Європа каже, що ми добре
фінансують ваші дослідження, але ви
також очікується, що ви підете цим шляхом
гм
um Open Access, тому що ваші результати
результати, які ви досягаєте в проектах
фінансується Європейською комісією
має бути доступним для ваших однолітків
а не схований десь під ембарго
цих відомих журналів
так, і я думаю, що Італії багато
є так багато аспектів, які ви не можете
навіть навіть як ми навіть не можемо пояснити
Мені цікаво, але для чого важливо
весь цей обмін як практика
обмін результатами та базами даних
існування uh існуючих uh баз даних, які
ваша власність є ух є
заходи на етапі підготовки до
пропозиції, які можуть бути a
договір про нерозголошення
зробив це, якщо у вас є, як деякі a
певні результати досліджень або певні
ресурси, які ви не хочете
гм, наші дискусії, які ви не хочете бачити
щоб ви могли пояснити, що в такому
контракт і пізніше, коли ти справді
щоб отримати фінансування, має бути Консорціум
угода, яка точно визначає, що є
ой, які проблеми є
виключені з цього проекту та залишаються
ваша власність, тому що ви входите в с
деякі ресурси, можливо, з величезним
базу даних, і ви не хочете нею ділитися
з усіма, крім вас, воно тримається, воно має залишитися
ваша власність, але є особливі е-е
тренінги з інтелектуальної власності
права і так далі але так собі є
люди ретельно розмірковували
про це відкрите наукове питання та
відкрити ну
гм і доступ до стоматологічних властивостей
сутності цих проблем у вас є один
проблема щодо запиту Марії
дії, які я бачу
хм, я можу, я можу взяти це, ну це
це гарне запитання, тому що ми є
мене часто запитують про це, але
насправді ні
Я просто уявляю, що я намагався
поясніть це футболом Марія Кюрі
Ліга Європи та чемпіони
ліга і звичайно
гм, якщо ви отримаєте
або якщо ви подаєте заявку на Марію Кюрі
Грант, я б завжди вказував у своєму
пропозиція щодо моєї наступної кар’єри
кроком є, наприклад, застосування дуги
підставу та провести власне дослідження
група це вказує на вашу кар'єру
розвитку, і це те, як я б
впоратися з цим, але, звичайно, немає
автоматизму так в основному, якщо ви говорите про
курс, на який вам потрібно буде подати заявку
ERC, щоб надати ваш послужний список і
звичайно, це добре, що ти маєш
був, наприклад, стипендіатом Марії Кюрі
і тоді ваші рецензенти побачать
добре, це має конкретний дослідник
ймовірно потенціал і це те, що ви
потрібно показати, що у вас є
науковий потенціал
головний дослідник очолити a
дослідницької групи, але, звичайно, немає
автоматизм, тому що ти ще пам'ятаєш
це про наукову досконалість і
це єдиний критерій і це
про високий ризик High Gain в основному так
тому важливо розуміти
це цей момент
тому я можу відповісти трохи після
наступне запитання, яке я побачив у чаті
тож як українська установа має a
можливість взяти участь протягом а
Консорціум ми кажемо, хто країни
заклад, якщо ми маємо власний проект
і там є інший або ми повинні
асоційована Асоційована країна слідувати
їхній проект теж добре, ми повинні бути
насамперед обережно
якщо проект з'являється з партнерством
тоді у вас спільна мета і кроки
де
партнери беруть участь спільно
принаймні певною мірою так, тому є
а не окремі проекти для кожної країни
ви знайдете, але є спільний хід
вперед, звичайно, є
у таких пропозиціях визначається розподіл праці
тому хтось зробив попередньо, повинен зробити
попередні дослідження, інші партнери повинні
наприклад, збирай інші речі, а потім це
збирається разом, щоб спільними зусиллями
так, вони можуть бути Беркширським, але
загальні цільові цілі, а також
заходи реалізуються спільно
у більшості випадків, звичайно, якщо у вас є
побратими це була б інша ситуація
де одне як підтримка іншого
у встановленні певних питань або якщо ви
це загальне
um uh Excellence Інноваційні сфери, які
побудовані так, як ми мали в
відбілювання, то у вас є саме
мета, яка є спільною, тому ви
спільно створити нову екосистему або
покращити існуючу стіну так нормально
у вас, звичайно, є спільні зусилля
може бути спільна робота, яка була б ну
інформації немає окремих
проектів для кожного партнера є
координатор, який також отримує
попереднє фінансування від комісії, що
поширює його і є т. зв
робочі пакети що та завдання що
структуруйте цей процес таким чином
певний
діяльність, яка налаштована, а потім це
визначив, які Партнери мають робити внески
і ось як усі ці проекти
звісно, ​​результати в бюджеті
для кожного партнера, який має відношення до
який, що це таке, як призначено в
ці завдання, тож загальне
структура, так що це проект
суглобів, через які він розвивається спільно
протягом кількох років
це зрозуміло, я сподіваюся, що так
Я хотів би додати Фелікса, я маю на увазі це
мабуть, загальна проблема для України
але, як на мене, це неправильно
сприйняття, тому що якщо ви скажете, що ми маємо
наш власний проект, і вони мають свій
власний проект, як ми можемо працювати разом
на мій погляд, це неправильний підхід
тому що вам потрібно, я маю на увазі, якщо ви
визначити дзвінок на європорталі Horizon
і ви готові взяти участь
цей дзвінок вам, звичайно, потрібен
Консорціум партнерів, а потім це
Ваша робота — знайти тих партнерів, яких ми
говорили про пошук партнера
фінансування та тендерні можливості
портал, на який я щойно опублікував ще одне посилання
партнерський розділ euroxis
портал, і ось як ви можете знайти
партнерів, які в основному мої заг
порекомендувати б ви самі
має краще знати, хто поруч правий
партнер для цього дослідження, оскільки ви
ви повинні спілкуватися з
ваші європейські колеги ви самі
варто відвідувати конференції і так далі навіть
цифрові, але вам потрібні ці контакти
самі і ніхто не зможе
надати вам це з тими
зв'язуватися тільки з вами самим ви повинні
почати в якийсь момент
um розширення вашої мережі та
намагаючись залучити партнерів не лише з
Наприклад, Східна Європа ззовні
але з усієї Європи це шлях
Ви повинні піти, на мій погляд, я сподіваюся, що це так
ясно і я
думаю, до мене є одне запитання
щодо грантів ERC
гм
гм це в основному
це в основному е-е
немає жодних умов, подібних до вас
спочатку потрібні, щоб виграти старт
Надайте, і тоді ви зможете завантажити або
тоді ви маєте право подати заявку
авансових грантів немає такого немає
стан, але бути ух
щоб подати заявку на розширений грант, просто прочитайте
уважно опис, тому ми
потрібно, щоб бути дуже успішним
вчений, який має чудовий шлях
запису, тому з мого досвіду їх немає
багато людей у ​​всьому світі, які можуть це зробити
виконайте ці умови, тому, якщо ви прийдете
з великою науковою ідеєю, і це
це величезна перевага вашого ERC
послужний список важливий, але менший
важливіше вашої ідеї, якщо ви придумаєте
з чудовою ідеєю, і ви переконаєте всіх
ваші однолітки, і вони кажуть, вау, це а
чудово, і ніхто не зміг прийти до тями
ця ідея перед тим, як це ваш шлях
і навіть тоді ви можете подаватись на просунутий
Грант, сподіваюся, це зрозуміло
MSA неможливий у Jerome Я знаю MSA
це дуже можливо в Німеччині, що є
неможливо в Німеччині стипендія
стипендія означає, що ви не платите
внески на соціальне страхування
ви не платите податки у вас фікс
сума це ваша стипендія і це
це неможливо в Німеччині, тому що ми
хочу, щоб люди працювали за допомогою uh
звичайні трудові договори, які вони
мають нормальну медичну страховку, що вони
мати умови соціального страхування
вони та їхні родини і так далі і так далі
вперед, тому ми не дозволяємо
гм стипендії, але MSA важлива і
дуже вітаємо в Німеччині
і я, наскільки я знаю, це те саме
у Греції я добре знаю своє спогадування
ну я маю на увазі, що там схоже
так що це можливо, але це має дотримуватися
правила
зсередини країни, так що
насправді те повідомлення, яке було потрібне
правильно, оскільки зайнятість є національною
питання так, щоб поглибити цю тему зайнятості
це не питання Європи
комісійне наймання є нац
Очікується, що випуск англійської країни
надати Національний трудовий договір
а в Німеччині це завжди
включаючи соціальне забезпечення та
стипендії можуть бути можливими в деяких
країн, але як величезний величезний виняток
потім
так є
завдання, які ви вже можете виконати, ви можете переглянути
робочі програми
де ви знайдете свою організацію
тематично
гм, ви також можете подивитися, що є
як команди, які з’являються у вашому
організація до нас їде за темою
це те, що ви вже можете зробити
також можна ввести
інформаційні дні наступного тижня
тематично більш насичений, ніж ми
могли забезпечити
хм це було б справді схоже на перший
кроки, які ви можете легко виконати
так що маємо
наступний
запитання
Я думаю, ви маєте на увазі Марі
Кюрі
товариш індивідуальні товариства коли
ви говорите про індивідуальні гранти
так
хм, я не буду говорити за
міністерство, я думаю, Вікторія все ще тут
вона може прокоментувати це, але
хм, наскільки я знаю
ні, вам просто потрібен ваш господар
установа у вашій країні перебування в
Європа, і вони повинні бути готові
подайте заявку разом з вами для цього
товариство і це все, щоб ви не робили
потрібен офіційний дозвіл міністерства
але гм Вікторія, будь ласка
прокоментуйте це так, справді дякую
так, ти правий, тобі нічого не потрібно
затвердження офіційними листами від
міністерство лише від вашої установи
Дуже дякую, сподіваюся, це зрозуміло
можливо, можливо, також для подальших дій
інституційне проти особистого
участь Я маю на увазі, коли ви хочете приєднатися
певний проект Консорціум це
складається з партнерів і вас
ніби представляють також партнера
тоді вам потрібна внутрішня установа
згода, що це можна зробити, і
це потрібно обговорити внутрішньо
які реальні можливості, а також
що таке
очікується від вас у закладі
це дуже важливо, тому що це часто
викликає непорозуміння, якщо він новий
Карма, я маю на увазі, тоді це важко
щоб організувати та зрозуміти, якщо
організація вже зареєстрована в
додаток для одягу тому що там
є унікальним номером для кожної сутності, яка
це організація бере участь
ну це можна перевірити, ви можете перевірити
це є, ви можете дізнатися, якщо є
є такою ідентифікацією
виберіть уже доступний номер для вашого
організації, а потім ви можете отримати лайк
також у контакті з особою, яка є
керуючи цим обліковим записом, і ви можете
приєднайтеся до цього номера також, якщо ви зареєструєтесь
на цьому порталі, тому це там
є багато технічних деталей, які не є такими
складно, але ви повинні їх зробити, але
принаймні ця проблема ця конкретна
проблема вашої особистості як є
має бути частиною більшої організації
береться до уваги, оскільки має
наслідки для як uh це зустрічає
уточнення так, чи можете ви піти на дзвінок
так, чи можете ви піти як партнер для але
зазвичай це дуже вітається, але це так
також це впливає на те, як, як
ви повинні зробити і що таке
оцінив, який спосіб залучення для
впевнений, що не оцінений наближається до одного
за день до закінчення судового строку начальники
так що краще домовитися вчасно
і це часто нелегко, тому що
міг бути такий досвід
вам відомі, і це добре
організуйте та дізнайтеся, хто головний
і як це можливо, якщо ваш
організація також не залучена
добре звернутися до юридичного НКП, оскільки
є національний контактний пункт, який
займається цими питаннями прав
участь у проектах і він вона може
підтримувати їх легко це дуже легко в
на стадії застосування, але пізніше
має бути суттєво підтримано як
Ну
Я думаю, що це головне
повинні бути також підписи під час
процес подання заявки, тому це має бути
влаштовано без цього не йде
[Музика]
Я опублікував посилання на цього учасника
шукайте, тому в основному перейдіть за цим посиланням
ви можете ви можете ідентифікувати свій
заклад, щоб ви могли перевірити, чи
ваша установа вже зареєстрована
але справді це пікове число це
унікальний піковий номер є першим кроком
оскільки ви можете подати заявку лише як a
Установа для фінансування, якщо у вас є
це пікове число
і на цій сторінці ви можете в основному
перевірте, чи є у вас вже великий
номер або банку, або ви можете зареєструвати свій
Заклад
так, можливо, добре запитати тих, хто
відповідальні до реєстрації у нас були
навіть у нашій організації дадуть вам a
50 чоловік у нас було одночасно два піку
коди, і ми не знали чому, оскільки
був один колега, який не знав
процедуру та щойно запросив новий
одне, і це часто трапляється, а потім це
дуже важко позбутися другого
так що краще не турбувати
адміністрація у цьому відношенні просто
перевірте, чи є у вашій організації
потім вони домовилися про зустріч і і
уточнити нормально процедури вже є
добре налаштовано, оскільки багато ваших
організації брали участь
але навіть в досвідченій організації
це може статися, хоча я маю на увазі
добре
Я думаю, що всі втомилися, і ми
можливо, слід закінчити
хм, Вікторія, ви б хотіли звернутися
учасників з фіналом
заява міністерства
насправді дякую
гм, я просто хотів би подумати
думаю в першу чергу про цю подію вам
за таку чудову презентацію
інтенсивний, я вважаю, як інформаційний
я дуже радий, що їх багато
учасників
може мати можливість приєднатися до нас
сьогодні не лише через цю платформу, але
також через нашу трансляцію на YouTube
велике спасибі, я просто хотів подякувати
для вашої організації, так, це так
насправді це був чудовий інформаційний день
є багато інформації і в будь-якому випадку
якщо хтось із учасників має такі
додаткові питання до міністерства
Будь ласка, надішліть ці запитання мені
електронною поштою, і я буду радий зв’язатися з вами
тому якомога швидше, тож дякую
велике спасибі Вікторія
гм тоді
потім
Фелікс, ти хочеш так
так, я думаю, це було чудово мати
стільки відгуків від аудиторії, так
це було не в усіх випадках
інші країни, наскільки я знаю
люди соромилися робити свій внесок
е-е, але тут у нас було це е-е, це гарно е-е
взаємодія з усіма вами
Я маю на увазі, що більше нічого сказати
дякую Вікторія за організацію
лайк і підхід до всіх контактів
ви мали, тому що це було справді
дивно, що так багато реєстрацій
добре, не всі з'явилися, але ми цього не робимо
неважливо, так, але я маю на увазі, що це було
справді чудово мати такий високий інтерес
справді дякую
дякую глядачам за багато
за багато питань, так, це справді
добре
велике спасибі також з мого боку
усі, тому не соромтеся запитувати
запитання
це посилання на записи YouTube
знову до Вікторії, ймовірно, ми не робимо
є посилання на запис YouTube, але я
надія
Вікторія, якщо так, я поділюся цим
прямо зараз у вікні чату, так